This is Jocko podcast number one 53 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening,
Congressional resolution honoring the veterans of Helicopter Attack Light
Squadron three and their families,
whereas helicopter attack light squadron three here in after in this resolution
referred to as how three began its history as detachments of Navy Helicopter
Combat Support Squadron One HC one which began helicopter gunships operations in
support of Navy Brown water,
special operations and army units in the Mekong Delta of South Vietnam on
September 19th,
1966 whereas the detachments of HC one adopted the name see Wolfe's.
Whereas how three was officially established on April 1st,
1967 in Vung Tau South Vietnam and was the only active duty navy helicopter
gunships squadron in the history of naval aviation.
Whereas during the squadrons existence,
nearly 3000 veterans of how three displayed extraordinary courage in support of
United States military and political objectives in Vietnam,
whereas 44 veterans of how three gave their lives and supportive military
operations in the Mekong Delta Vietnam.
Whereas the extraordinary performance of the veterans of how three earned
numerous unit citations in coatings,
six presidential unit citations,
seven Navy Unit Commendations,
one meritorious unit commendation,
a Republic of Vietnam meritorious unit commendation,
and the Vietnam Service Medal.
Whereas the valor of the veterans of how three earned five Navy crosses,
31 silver stars to Legion of Merit metals,
five Navy and Marine Corps metals,
219 distinguished flying crosses 156 purple hearts,
101 bronze stars.
142 republic of Vietnam Gallantry crosses over 16,000 air medals,
439 navy commendation medals and 228 navy achievement metals making it possibly
the most decorated navy squadron during the Vietnam War.
Yeah.
Whereas the maintenance and administrative personnel of how three contributed
greatly to the success of the nine,
how three detachments operating throughout the Mekong Delta providing the
detachments with superb maintenance support and logistics.
Whereas how three flew over 130,000 hours of combat and logistical,
whereas how three inflicted several thousand casualties on the enemy forces.
Whereas how three performed 1,530 medical evacuations,
whereas how three delivered over 37,000 passengers and over 1 million pounds of
cargo.
And whereas how three was disestablished in March,
1972 at being three south Vietnam as part of the Vietnamese program,
leaving behind it,
a combat and humanitarian record recognizing,
recognized as bringing great credit upon the United States navy and its role in
the Vietnam War.
Now therefore be it resolved
that the House of representative one honors the service,
courage and sacrifice of the veterans of how three two honors the families of
how three veterans for their support three expresses its condolences to the
families and comrades of those killed in action and for recognizes how three as
a unique squadron in the history of naval aviation
and that
resolution of recognition was made in 2010 actually 38 years after the sea
wolves were disestablished in Vietnam.
And that is a long time to wait for recognition.
And this is because,
well,
for one thing,
they weren't looking for recognition,
but also too much of the world.
The seaward.
See Wolves were relatively
unknown
for me,
having grown up in the seal teams,
I actually knew about the sea wolves.
I knew about the reputation from the Vietnam era seals that held them in the
absolute highest regard
possible.
Okay.
Then they were considered extremely courageous,
courageous,
sometimes beyond courageous.
They were incredible pilots and the highly aggressive gunners and the teams that
maintain and kept the aircraft flying it really horrible conditions.
They were known for getting the job done.
And there's one thing that always stuck in my mind when I heard stories about
the sea wolves in Vietnam,
and that was this,
simply if you called them,
they would come
and it didn't matter if it was day or night,
sunny skies or typhoon rains,
a calm extraction or a hot landing zone filled with enemy fire to the seawalls.
None of that mattered.
Okay?
What mattered is that the troops on the ground needed help and if you called the
sea wolves,
okay,
they would come.
Yeah.
And it is an honor today to have one of these men here with us to tell us about
this.
Relatively unknown.
But at the same time,
legendary squadron of Naval Aviation Helicopter Attack Squadron Light,
how three the sea wolves.
And we have Dennis Rally,
naval officer,
naval aviator and of course Seawolf Sir,
absolutely honored to have you on the show.
Thank you for coming
Jocko.
Hi.
Thank you.
And you echo a for the opportunity to be here.
It's uh,
it's something that I didn't want to do.
If,
you know,
you hear the old saw about,
uh,
you don't talk about,
the war.
And I think that's true of most all of the guys that I knew and flew and fought
with.
We just don't talk about it except over a beer in a bar somewhere with that guys
we've trusted our lives to,
however,
my wife Stinky and my son and daughter when they heard about this opportunity
told me,
you got to do this.
You got to help keep the reputation of the seawalls alive.
And I don't think at reputation,
he's a lot of buildup on my part.
Uh,
I'm here to honor the 44 of our brothers who weren't able to come on back with
us.
And I'm here to help share a little bit of history about the,
uh,
the squadron.
And I'm here to thank everyone of you swinging Dick Gunners,
who helped me get my little pink body back without any additional holes in it.
Those guys are phenomenal.
I mean,
they're really something,
but we'll get into that.
Uh,
it's a pleasure to be here.
I am.
I looking forward to the conversation.
Uh,
I'm still scratching my head as to why I'm here because you guys have giant saw
on the show.
You just had a fella who was,
uh,
a highly decorated marine,
infantry officer.
He,
uh,
went on to get a law degree.
He went on who work in the Va.
He became the secretary of the navy.
He,
uh,
became a congressman from the great story of the state of Virginia.
And,
uh,
oh,
by the way,
it was a little known candidate for president of the U S and party politics
aside.
This country would have been better off if Jim Webb had been our president.
Totally agree.
Yeah.
And I can say that,
uh,
not from a,
you know,
just a casual,
uh,
a reading of his bio.
I know Jim because he was a classmate of mine at the Naval Academy.
I know Jim because it was a company made a mine at the Naval Academy
and I know Jim to be the,
uh,
the,
the kind of a man that,
uh,
I would hope my son would become just a great guy.
I can also say that I know Jim because for a brief time,
plebe summer,
we roomed together.
So you're looking at one of the only guys that you'll ever meet who is proud to
share the fact that he slept with the secretary of the navy.
So yeah,
we're,
we're here to spread the word and,
and have a little fun.
The,
uh,
the one thing that was really important about a recent past is a AC Wolf Wolfer
Union.
We have reunions every,
every couple of years and now many reunions more frequently.
But this one who was a pretty special,
yeah,
it was about two months ago.
We,
we gathered on the flight deck of the Midway,
uh,
for the premier of a documentary called scrambled to see wolves.
They had a big inflatable screen on the flight deck and we were all up there
laughing and scratching.
Uh,
one thing that I noticed about the entire experiences,
man over those guys look old now.
I mean with the,
the,
uh,
the movie,
the documentary was very well shot.
It's a actually being released on,
uh,
KPBS and PBS.
And I assume that shortly after that it'll be available on youtube.
But,
uh,
it,
it gave us a sense of pride and I think I can speak for everyone that it gave us
a,
a little greater sense of belonging,
uh,
based upon the fact that,
our,
our story could now
be told.
Yeah,
no,
that's a,
I I've watched in,
anybody can watch it.
You can,
if you Google scramble the Sea Wolves Kpbs uh,
the,
it'll pop up and you can watch it.
You know,
there's no email to sign up for.
It's free.
That's how you can,
you can watch it.
Um,
let's,
let's talk about the seawall.
So let's talk a little bit about your past because I think,
uh,
you're,
I mean starting with your,
your dad being a pilot and now let's start with that and,
and what that was like growing up.
Well,
my dad would really be pissed off at you for calling him a pilot because dad was
an aviation who were under distress and he knew that the guys in the back,
we are doing the job and the guys up front,
we're just a steering the bus.
No,
my dad,
William John Raleigh was a,
a hell of a guy.
He was an interesting man.
And that's the nicest thing you can say about somebody.
I think dad was a kind of a guy who could walk into a room and,
uh,
full of strangers and an hour later walk out and everybody thought it was their
new best friend.
Good Guy,
great guy.
But he comes from a long line of Warriors.
My,
uh,
grandfather who married my grandmother from Hilo.
Uh,
yeah,
he,
uh,
he fought in a world war one.
I have a wonderful picture at home of my mom and her three brothers,
uh,
taken during World War II.
And,
uh,
Uncle Walt,
who's there in his marine corps uniform.
Uncle Bob is there in his navy blues.
And My,
uh,
my uncle Jim is there and his army air force uniform.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
when World War II broke out,
and my,
my dad and his brother,
my uncle herb both joined the navy.
Uh,
Dad went on into aviation ordinance and uh,
came out the other end of the pipe after piece is one of the last of the Tojo
chiefs,
the guy who made chief and a little over three years.
Uh,
uh,
he's an interesting fellow and a leadership lesson.
A number one for me was the way he helped me grow as I was,
uh,
coming up.
You would think that a chief petty officer in the Navy,
it can be very gruff and directive and they can,
and they are when it's required.
But Dad's never told me,
go do this.
He'd say,
have you ever considered,
have you ever thought about,
have you ever,
and he brought it into practice one day when,
uh,
I was,
just,
uh,
getting ready for college and uh,
trying to decide where I was going to go.
He had just come back from a mid cruise and he had one of his [inaudible] a
pilot and Naval Academy Grad.
I invite me over to his house for dinner.
I know,
I thought that was a little strange,
but I was pretty excited about it.
The,
a guy came and picked me up in a brand new yellow corvette and took me over to
his home and introduced me to his drop dead gorgeous Swedish wife.
Now Dad didn't have to say you should go to the naval academy for the experience
in learning leadership.
He brought it down to,
to a level that I could understand if thought you'd get issued a sweetest wine.
Well,
actually what I want to Jocko was somebody five,
eight,
five,
nine long straight,
blonde hair head bitchin bod.
What'd he come?
Completely intelligent and,
uh,
imbued with a meeting instincts of a wild and making heat.
But what the good Lord saw fit to pair me up with was stinky and she's a stumpy
little brown here,
your old that's just ornery as a sacral wild cats.
So yeah,
he ain't it funny how it all works out.
Uh,
so,
so you,
you,
you go meet this pilot and did that,
did that flip the switch in your head?
Well,
I,
I always knew I wanted it to be a naval aviator.
It's just something that I,
that I wanted.
I had initially had dreams of going in and flying spats that day one was a just
a hell of a weapons carrier in a close air support mission that,
uh,
was a non parallel in my way of thinking.
Uh,
they,
uh,
got a lot of guys out of the shit.
Uh,
but uh,
that didn't work out because the aircraft was being retired is I was going
through flight school.
Uh,
the thought of going to the Naval Academy was always intriguing to me and I
didn't know that I'd be able to make that,
but I was one of the,
uh,
you know,
I'm sort of large and I was,
uh,
one of the only Navy,
dependents who are into athletics.
Cubis Saki high school on Okinawa,
where I went through all four years of high school.
And,
uh,
the,
senior,
a naval officer on the island had roomed with a hard and the football coach at
navy.
They did a,
a quick scout and,
uh,
told me to take a competitive exam and I'd,
be considered for the academy.
I,
uh,
had had a year to,
to waste while I was waiting to get into the academy.
So I went to Berkeley.
This is in the 1963 64 school year,
which was very colorful.
Mario Salvo was up there.
Doing is,
uh,
is a dirty word movement on the steps of the administration building was,
it was ugly.
My parents lived across the hill in Walnut Creek,
California.
And every time a news was over,
I'd get a frantic call from my mother.
Are you okay?
Yeah,
mom,
I'm okay.
It's,
yeah.
But at any rate,
uh,
following that,
you're at Berkeley,
I had every seat of presidential a appointment and even though he was,
he had,
uh,
had been assassinated,
John Kennedy's signatures is on that.
Yeah.
And I went back to the,
uh,
to the navy,
fell in love with a crew.
And I can honestly say that if it hadn't been for rowing at navy,
I probably wouldn't have made it through.
I probably would have quit.
Which is something that you would have been pissed off about
is,
uh,
and why is that?
Because it gave you something to focus on.
It gave you an outlet.
I exactly,
uh,
crew is hands down the,
the greatest team sport that you can imagine.
It,
uh,
if even one person is not pulling their weight is not exactly in sync.
The rhythm of the boat,
uh,
suffers a,
it'll be dragged down and everyone will know exactly that.
The reason for that,
you can tell by the size of the puddle,
the way the boat is a set,
it's,
it's phenomenal.
So it's a great lesson in group leadership and that everyone has to be a leader
in that Shell to put their there,
the maximum that they can into it to make the boat move.
If you get a chance,
read a book called the boys in the boat.
It's at,
I've heard of that.
Yeah.
It's got great insight into what Roy is all about.
And you guys should be up on other sports.
And so you,
you,
you row at the Naval Academy.
How has your,
how has your,
since you've kind of grew up in the navy,
your dad was a chief and it must've been at least somewhat for the,
you know,
the shock in awe of chill instructors and upperclassmen and all that stuff.
It wasn't the,
uh,
the drill instructors or the,
the upperclassmen.
It was the chicken shit.
I had a,
uh,
a guy in our company,
they just hated me and he'd stand me up in the passageway and they had a plastic
baseball bat and beat me in the chest with it.
It's a non event,
you know,
funk,
funk.
But if I saw that guy again,
I would rip his head off because it was just so juvenile.
I was a couple of years older than my classmates for a number of reasons.
I flunked kindergarten,
but at any rate it was,
you just don't do things like that.
There's,
there's,
there's no,
there's no leadership lessons.
There's no benefit to be had from some of the stuff that was going on in there.
But when I got out there on the water with my teammates,
you know,
it all just went away.
Yeah.
There's something to be learned from having to put up with such crap.
And I think there's two ways people go with it.
Some sometimes they go with like,
oh,
I'm going to be able to do that one day in and give people a bunch of shit about
whatever.
And some people go,
okay,
I'm never going to act like that.
Yeah.
Oh,
and then how,
and um,
so you were Jim Webb's roommate plebe summer,
uh,
just for a few days,
but we were in the same company for all four years.
Yeah.
And then he's a heck of a guy.
Uh,
no,
it was awesome.
It was a real honor to have him on here.
And you know,
he,
he told a similar story and he wrote about it and it's in some of his books,
which was,
you know,
a guy just smacking him in the ass with a,
some kind of bat.
It was our song book.
And they're telling him he needs to say,
you know,
just admit that it hurts and he wouldn't admit it.
Yeah.
But same thing,
you know,
he's like,
he,
what did he say?
He said,
you know,
I don't hold anything against those guys that did that to me,
but I remember their names.
So I think they've made the list for Jim Webb.
Um,
and then how did you end up picking,
so you,
you already automatically knew you wanted to be a pilot?
Absolutely.
And was that hard to get selected for that?
Uh,
no.
It was a service selection is done based on class rank and I graduated in the
top 10% over the bottom third of my class and that was sufficient to get me in
there.
And Aviation,
since I couldn't fly the spad I I really wanted to go jets,
sorry guys,
I have to admit that.
But,
uh,
due to due to my size,
and my anthropometric measurements,
if I had to punch out,
I would have a lift my knees on the Glare Shield of the,
uh,
the trainers.
How tall are you?
Six.
Four,
yeah.
Big.
Um,
this was,
you know,
clearly,
and Jim Webb talked about this when he was on the podcast.
You know,
he's,
he was the guy in charge of hanging up the names of the,
that had been killed.
And,
and yet when I had Charlie plum on who graduated,
I think in 64,
or he showed up in 64,
no,
graduated 64.
Vietnam wasn't even on the,
on the radar.
That's for them.
And for you guys,
it,
you know,
1967,
1968,
it had to,
you know,
you had to have known,
okay,
I'm going to fight in Vietnam.
When you walk into mother be Bancroft Hall,
you go into the return to which was a very large open area.
And when we started losing a are a former classmates,
the graduate,
uh,
I'm sure Jim explained,
but if you put a poster board up there with the pitcher out of the lucky bag and
a,
a brief bio and a,
and not a description,
but where they died.
And initially it was just a onesies twosies,
but pretty soon that the march went all the way around the Rotunda and they had
to move it up into memorial hall.
Uh,
and it really brought home the fact that the,
this is,
this is serious,
this is a,
you know,
you're making up your minds whether or not you wanted a dedicate your lives to
do the defense of this country.
And it might come at a considerable cost.
And for 44 of our brothers,
it certainly did 44 [inaudible] Willis didn't make it back.
And
I'm sort of an emotional guy,
but,
uh,
one of the few times that I've
really cried
openly and unashamedly was at the wall
scene,
a scene,
a couple of my gunner's up there,
just a really brought it home to me.
Amazing people got to resolve.
So that's,
that's what you know,
you're getting into upon commissioning and so you,
you get commissioned and you graduate in [inaudible] 68 your class 68.
Right.
And you then you go to Pensacola,
Florida.
Is that where you go to flight school?
That's right.
And
that's what you talk us a little bit through the flight school path.
You show up,
you learn to fly.
What a t 38.
Is that what you're wearing on?
No,
we,
you started out at at and t 34 and that,
that's there's,
there's been a change in the way they,
uh,
they uh,
instruct naval aviators now when we were going through,
you had to do the flight,
the fixed wing flight syllabus first before you could get into helicopters.
And then you'd go through the helicopter,
a syllabus.
And then after that,
those of us that God orders to Vietnam,
we'd uh,
go up to Fort Rucker and the army would a instruct us in tactics in the armament
systems.
Uh,
they did,
they did a good job in preppiness and then send us overseas and the rest of it
would be done in country.
So the,
the,
the training that we received along the way was a,
was excellent pit a,
a lot of it was just like a back at the academy.
They told us that,
uh,
hey guys,
if the education you receive here at the United States Naval Academy costs the
taxpayer approximately $250,000,
which was a lot of money back then.
And our reply was,
yeah,
but you stick it up our butts,
a nickel at a time.
So you know,
you know,
had you,
so now you're in the pipeline for,
for helicopters.
Had you heard of sea wolf that this time,
were you hearing about it?
Did you,
is it something that you said,
oh,
I want to go do that?
We were just starting to hear about it.
And you know,
it wasn't a fully developed in my mind.
It,
uh,
that's uh,
where I wanted to go,
but it quickly became,
ah,
there is a,
a,
a purpose for every element in the military from the guys who's swabs the decks
all the way on up.
But I didn't want to be a bus driver.
I didn't want to be a guy who bored holes in the sky.
So this being the Seawolf immediately appealed to me as an opportunity to be
able to,
I don't know,
to payback.
It's,
it's a funny thing and I'll jump ahead a little here,
but,
uh,
I have a cousin who is very close to me.
She's like a sister to me and I'd never really thought about questions like you
just asked.
But,
uh,
after immediately after I got back from Vietnam,
she was driving me on out to family home in Walnut Creek,
California,
and without taking your eyes off the road,
she said,
how can you do it?
And I thought about that for just a minute and said,
well,
it was pretty easy.
I went over there to bring as many of our guys home safely as I could.
And in some ways I fail.
In some ways I succeeded,
but that's it.
I was enough of a student,
uh,
to,
to understand that the domino effect.
Uh,
certainly that,
that wasn't in my thinking.
Uh,
you know,
you're thinking sort of 10 yards,
10 yards,
but uh,
in the air it's a little a more expansive,
it's,
it's the guys that you're flying with,
the guys in your flat fire team,
the guys on your debt,
the guys who were a,
the maintainers back in a BIM Toohey,
they're the,
uh,
they're the guys you think about and that's why you do it.
Okay.
So did you get to select,
you get done with thumb,
you get done with the training?
Did you get to select,
hey,
I want to go to the squadron new Vietnam?
Uh,
pretty much,
yes.
It was there a long list for that day.
They were there.
I'm sure they were more volunteers than,
uh,
then,
I got accepted.
I don't know the mechanics of that.
I asked for it and that.
Got It.
How did that look like?
Showing up in Vietnam,
I was the only officer assigned to the Sea Wolves who,
uh,
took that a reverse freedom flight on into Saigon.
And I got there and they shuffled me off to the Annapolis Hotel,
which I thought was a little unusual,
but,
uh,
you know,
I had a couple of days to kill because there wasn't any transfer transport down
to,
uh,
to BIM two e and I knew a dear friend of mine,
who was it,
uh,
in debt to it,
Nah,
bay.
And he'd got over there before I did.
So I figured,
no baby,
that's not too far away.
I'm going to go visit him.
And the next morning I,
uh,
check out a 45 put it in my gym bag.
I'm in civvies.
They didn't like us roaming around town in onesies,
uh,
in uniform.
So I jumped on a navy bus out to not obey.
I'm just having a great time talking to the guys at the debt there and learn a
little about what's going on.
And
it comes time to,
to leave and it's probably about 1630.
And I say,
well,
I better get back.
And they say,
well you just missed the last bus but don't worry about it.
You can take a petty cab.
So here I am,
a brand new in country.
I've got the Zipper in my uh,
on my gym bag open with my hand,
very close to it.
And this a Vietnamese fellow out with his pedaling away taking me back to the,
the hotel.
It took us about an hour to get back there and a,
I tipped him generously because I'm not a light fellow.
I was a lot lighter then.
But uh,
you know,
here I am my first day in country and I'm going to get greased.
So,
yeah,
tell us if you wouldn't mind some of the,
about the formation that sea wolves,
because it's,
it's a very cool story about the Mekong Delta,
about the way things,
the way the enemy moved through the Mekong Delta and through the wrong sat
special zone and there was no roads and the only way to get around with water,
if you want to maybe expand on that just so people can kind of get a feel for,
for what started this whole thing off.
Sure,
sure.
The,
uh,
the Mekong Delta is fed by a waters from the Himalayas.
It comes on down and spreads out into a broad,
a quasar.
I always see Anik area,
basically it's mud and crap and brown water and a HIMSS,
the Brown water navy.
But at any rate,
the,
um,
there are very few roads that do anything but connect major cities in the meek
on,
uh,
back then.
And consequently it's just about all the traffics moved by a Sam pen,
uh,
or,
or junk.
And that's the way people got around the,
uh,
infiltration that the Nva and,
the,
uh,
the VC practice came my largely either on foot by bicycle or by boat in order to
counteract that,
a task force.
So one,
one six,
a was put into place.
Game warden was the,
uh,
the operational mission and we were there to interdict that traffic in
personnel,
ammunition,
and a food logistics that was moving down into the delta.
The,
uh,
army,
I took that mission on first,
actually flying off a couple of,
uh,
Ltds,
that were a rigged with a,
uh,
this makes you flight deck.
But,
uh,
that didn't work out too well.
And,
uh,
this is not saying anything against the army,
but a,
in their syllabus,
they weren't trained on instruments in navy.
We were rigorously first in a fixed wing and then in helicopters.
So we were used to flying in the shit and the navy and the army was not,
and that's,
that's because the navy has to fly at sea and land on,
on,
on ships,
different mission.
That's it.
Different missions at the time.
The Ai,
the army,
uh,
that outgrew that.
But it was a,
it was painful.
They had had a different mission than we did.
So,
uh,
they,
they had a,
a unit that was assigned to our op con and they would fly a cover for a,
for the small boats now.
And those were primarily the pbrs and the swift boats.
We didn't see many swift boats up,
had been luck.
Uh,
we were working with a PBR sailors,
a PBR patrol boat.
River is a 32 foot fiberglass luxury boat that was stripped clean and it was
highly maneuverable,
but it was a,
I say,
stripped clean of everything that was non essential.
They were very lightweight,
uh,
had a little armor at all,
but they were very heavily armed.
And these boats,
do you talk about guys with a brass balls?
They'd poke up into,
uh,
these impossibly narrow canals and up a little riverlettes,
just looking for trouble.
And it frequently came their way.
So the army was,
uh,
attempting to work with them.
There were all sorts of,
uh,
a minor operational,
a problem,
problems to overcome,
uh,
who's calling out the missions?
Uh,
uh,
but,
the support area is,
it's just wasn't working well.
So at the navy decided that,
uh,
we needed a navy squadron and they've turned HC one,
the fleet angels though,
uh,
to put,
put a few debts in place to help provide cover for the,
uh,
the Brown water navy.
And by Brown water navy,
I mean the small boat guys,
the seals,
any navy,
Navy,
uh,
a vessel that was down in the,
in the McAllen.
And,
uh,
it wasn't working well with the,
the army HC one picked it up.
It started working very well,
uh,
because they understood the navy's mission much better than the army.
And they were,
uh,
equipped with the,
capabilities to fly both at night and in bad weather.
And,
uh,
I don't know if you've been in monsoon before that it's shitty flight.
It is really bad.
So,
uh,
as a,
as you've already mentioned,
on April fool's day in a 67,
uh,
they decided that they,
a in country squadron was a required and a,
that responsibility was shifted from HC one to how three.
Uh,
we grew to having non nine detachments,
uh,
that were scattered throughout the Delta is to,
give us a quick reaction time to virtually a,
any,
any area in the Mekong.
And,
uh,
each detachment had a two aircraft assigned.
It had a,
uh,
two full crews for each aircraft and that was about it.
But let me,
let me give you a little info on,
uh,
the noble you h one.
Bravo.
I love that aircraft.
It was a piece of crap.
It really was,
but it got us out of,
uh,
out of a lot of trouble every time we flew it just for people that are less
than,
that's the classic Vietnam Huey aircraft.
That's,
that's what you see.
That's what you see in movies.
That's it.
Yeah.
There really was sort of a,
a McHale's navy,
uh,
that,
Kay cachet that was attached to the sea wolves.
Uh,
the army was just getting rid of their bravo models to go to this,
to the Charlies,
which had,
uh,
several hundred,
greater horsepower or more maneuverable.
I Blah,
blah,
blah.
And they had a,
some old Bravo's sitting around.
And rather than shipping them back to the bone yard or destroying them in place,
they gave them to the navy.
So frequently we had a lot of rebuilding to do before we turn these guys loose.
But God bless the army,
they gave us a,
they gave us our,
uh,
our aircraft,
support for the Bravo and the navy chain was not the best.
So you've,
it's easy to say,
beg,
borrow or steal a borrower.
Steel is what we did quite well,
quite well.
Our guys were incredible.
We achieve at,
grabbed a couple of guys and go out and come back with exactly what we needed.
And you don't ask a question about that.
You just put it into play.
Uh,
so the,
uh,
the nine debts to a helicopters in each,
each shoe Huey was,
uh,
basically configured with two seven shot rocket pods,
a 2.75 folding thin aerial rockets.
We had a,
a pair of a sixties that were mounted a with a flexicon.
They a copilot control those.
But the,
uh,
the thing that really made us a unique and powerful was our door gunners when I
first got there.
And just,
just for a very short period of time or door gunners were still firing sixties
from the shoulder.
And that
was just an incredibly powerful tool in keeping the bad guys heads down during
our break and prepping the area for the next aircraft to,
uh,
to roll in.
So we typically have a door gunner on one side and on the other side,
if we were lucky,
uh,
50,
eventually this grew,
we,
uh,
got some mini guns,
most all of our,
uh,
debt birds.
Eventually I had a mini guns and the guys in the Backwood a fly them and it did
wonders for keeping,
uh,
keeping heads down.
As did the,
uh,
50 cows that we had.
Uh,
when we went from shoulder hair held sixties too.
There's a lesson,
there are guys would,
uh,
it wasn't unusual to see them standing out on the skids firing a cover for us.
That was a great good thing.
But it also a re resulted in Brasington ah,
the a sync elevator and the or,
uh,
it just wasn't really,
really acceptable.
If you brass the tail rotor,
he'll know about it.
It's a rough ride going back in.
But uh,
at an eight decided that no,
we can't have that
sort of tied the gunners hands by,
uh,
putting what they called it pussy pole in the a and the door and mounted the,
the 62 it,
well,
the guy's guy got more than a little inventive and decided that a,
if one 60 is good too,
would be better and mounted to one.
Uh,
yeah.
Here,
here we go again,
Hayden.
Thanks.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
mounted to sixties there and found out that they were blasting the,
the,
uh,
the tail rotor is still,
so what they did was they rotated each 90 degrees in opposing a directions and
all of a sudden the Brasin was no longer a much of a problem.
Did essentially the same way with our fifties.
Uh,
they,
uh,
mounted that so that a would,
a fire,
um,
uh,
90 degrees a longitudinally.
And that was a very powerful weapon for not only,
uh,
keeping,
keeping guys down,
but also,
uh,
it gave us a great degree of flexibility in the,
in the break.
And perhaps I should explain a,
that by the break we typically,
we would fly in a,
uh,
in a wagon wheel type,
type approach to helicopters,
uh,
roughly,
flying a one 80 out from one another.
So when his ruling on the target as the other is coming around behind it,
so when you then break off the target,
the next helicopter is in there,
a lane down it's fire.
And,
uh,
that,
50 would,
would really help us out in both,
uh,
identifying problem areas and taking care of the problem.
Yeah,
that's a great,
a great background.
And,
and you know,
even when you watch,
um,
a scramble,
the sea wolf,
the,
just,
all the footage is just,
it's unbelievable footage of the way you guys were flying and what the gunners
were doing gunners and hanging out and shooting underneath the bird back in the
other direction.
Yeah.
Hanging out by a gutters belt.
Um,
they might have invented the term gunner's belt.
I was,
go ahead.
There's a rite of passage that,
uh,
most of the,
fngs got.
And when I was in that Fng seat,
I learned it one dark and stormy night.
Uh,
we're flying along and mia and they hack,
they,
the aircraft commanders diverted my attention off to the left.
And when I turned back right here in the window of the Huey was one of my
gutters mooning me.
This is going to be fun.
And the other was,
uh,
if you were new to the debt as a pilot and you are going to get a collar full of
brass and it was really easy for them to do when they had the free guns,
I think got a little more inventive of later on how that that's,
that's freaking dangerous.
This smart.
Okay.
So speaking of fun,
one of the,
one of the things,
uh,
I pulled off of the website,
um,
sea wolf.org is you guys had this thing that you called the Wolf Graham,
which was sort of sort of like a sit rep for all the,
all the different elements that were out there.
And I think it paints a pretty good picture of the overall attitude.
And I pulled out one of the clips and I'm just going to read it.
So this is your debt debt for from beautiful downtown.
Ben Luck.
The fog cutters of debt for would like to wish everyone a merry monsoon season.
Only 10 shopping days left.
We'd better start with Lieutenant Jg who white before we forget him.
Everyone else has.
He,
he uh,
he though he was leaving in May but bupers forgot to assign them a new duty
station.
Admin forgot to request a flight booking for him and operations forgot to inform
him that this,
that is FTL papers had been signed,
but we're sure will finally fee,
but we're sure things will finally turn around for what's his name?
Lieutenant Deacon John Johnson left on rnr to Hawaii and lieutenant JG rookie
rich,
uh,
can't read the name.
Farmer farmer farmer was called into straightened out been toy bin Toohey
cutting us two,
three ftls and Amex commander Hammond,
we'll still have to fly every day even after the deacon gets back.
Boku map as Lieutenant Johnson is referred to by Mama Sohn won't be much good
for anything after coming back from Hawaii.
Rookie Rich's talent for hiding should be of great value in being Toohey.
Lieutenant Jg Check Carlos Steel has opened a chain of combination taco stand
slash mini gun exchange outlets with branches in Cuchi,
Tan,
Tan Anne and Ben luck with others soon to be opening in long been vain,
long and via TN.
Lieutenant Jg,
weird Harold to black is still looking for is mysteriously vanishing and 60
bolts.
Latest debt for basketball casualty was lieutenant JG buckets coffee named after
his golden touch on the court who got four stitches in his head after going for
a rebound.
Who Will it be an April three additions arrived at this past month.
Lieutenant Tom Rebola and Lieutenant Jg Denny Rally,
which is you sir,
are new in country and Lieutenant Jg,
Bill Beltz was shafted shifted from debt eight oh well with TV,
booze and all the attractions of the big city.
What more could you want as a,
one of our departed pilots used to say going home is for sissies.
So,
and you guys,
these are all vibed there.
They're fantastic to read.
I read that to a,
my buddy Dave Burke or I sent,
I sent him a copy of it and he said that's the best sit rep I've ever read in my
life.
So you guys had a,
you know,
it's,
it's good cause you know,
I,
I always talking and every vet that comes on here,
we kind of talk about how we have fun and that shows that.
And I guess getting mooned through your side window also shows that you guys
were having fun.
I don't know if the hot brass is a fun,
but you guys were having a great time and you guys were making it fun.
Um,
and at the same time,
man,
it was very intense and very dangerous.
One of the things that,
you know,
you,
you kind of threw it out there,
you said,
hey,
we put these debts all over the place so we could have a quick response time.
And what that meant was you guys were spread out in these debts so that you
could get two guys on the ground within a matter of minutes.
Tell me about that op tempo and what it was like when,
when they scrambled theZ wolfs
well,
we had,
uh,
two full crews for each one of our two birds.
And what that meant was you were 12 hours on 12 hours off,
three 65,
24,
whatever.
Uh,
in order to support the,
uh,
the Brown water navy,
when they got in the shit,
they,
they needed us right away and we could literally get off the deck,
uh,
in about three minutes.
And,
uh,
that put us out there,
quickly enough that we could probably get them out of trouble.
The,
the worst thing that could,
could happen to them,
in my estimation other than a losing someone as a,
is losing their engine because then they were just a out there with,
uh,
they were a grape,
no,
no place to go.
So all they could do is just absorbed the,
uh,
the incoming.
And with that in mind,
what we would do is go on out and try and first get,
get their heads down and then to start,
uh,
working the target.
Uh,
we had a very close relationship with the,
uh,
the PBR sailors very close.
Those guys,
uh,
were sticking their necks out every day and,
that the times they got in trouble,
we were happy to go and uh,
and uh,
try and extricate them on no matter up no matter what.
But one of the great quotes that I saw in the,
uh,
in the history that I was reviewing is,
the first contact that HC one made the,
the,
the two boats had gone out on patrol and had stumbled across a battalion size
element with a about 80 sampans and junks that we're trying to cross a river.
And the boats came under obviously intense fire when the sea sea wolves got
there.
A couple of,
uh,
minutes after this,
the,
uh,
incoming fire team league,
contacts the chief of the boat and says,
uh,
where do you want us to put in our strike?
And he said something like,
hell,
I want you boys to go in there and hold field day on those guys.
And that sort of,
the attitude that,
you know,
it is,
it's,
it,
it's an overused term,
but it's a brotherhood.
It,
it truly is.
A,
you did,
we do for those guys,
they were putting it all out.
Did you guys,
did you guys,
um,
pre brief with them for missions or how did you figure that out on the Oud?
You figure it out.
So did you know where they were going?
Did you know what their target was?
Did they pre-brief you?
Unfortunately,
we had a,
in intelligence that a was to put a kindly generally,
uh,
a piece of crap.
It wasn't very good for a number of reasons,
for a number of reasons.
But,
uh,
what we do is,
so we talked to the guys on the boats.
We know what the tactical situation was in the way,
and we would,
uh,
know where they were going and what,
what they were doing.
That is,
are you going out for a bunker?
Are you,
uh,
doing an insert with seals?
Uh,
we'd get that information from the,
uh,
from the team that was there.
Actually,
we didn't have a team.
I play as a,
just as a squad.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
we'd share the,
share the information,
so we've know about where they were going and what we do.
As soon as we got airborne,
his head for the,
uh,
the pre very spot and they'd get a update the info in route so that by the time
we got there,
we knew that where the fire was coming from,
what the situation was with the boats and where we were likely to put in our
first strike.
So the deconfliction as far as where you were shooting in friendly fire and all
that was,
I mean,
as long as,
as long as they tell you,
hey,
north,
north side of the river or something like that,
is that how you would deconflict and did you,
when you were supporting ground troops,
how the hell did you know who was who down there?
And we'd buy,
uh,
have him pop smoke.
And that generally worked.
But the worst thing that could happen is when you say pop bread and one shows up
right where you expect it.
And when shows up 100 meters on down.
So,
uh,
the bad guys had,
are kind of freaks in,
uh,
well I don't know if they had her freaks or not,
but they could certainly see a smooth ride and uh,
if they'd pop it also right,
same one and that could create a little that confusion.
But it also gave us a,
a,
uh,
Lucas points so that we could,
talk to the guys on the boats and they could direct our fire.
And one thing that's important about that,
the 2.75 holding fee and an aerial rocket,
uh,
was a great tool.
I didn't like it as much because it wasn't all that uncommon to have one of the,
the fins not open properly and then it had just go squirrelly and go anywhere.
If you had the aircraft,
uh,
trimmed up,
it could be an effective weapon,
but I didn't like to use it too far out because that gave it more of an
opportunity to,
uh,
to develop a mind of its own.
I use it more as a,
as a close in weapon.
So these,
the,
you'd be sitting in your,
in your hooch or whatever.
And you'd be stamped,
you know,
just standing by what was your 12 hour shift.
And then all of a sudden the radio call would come in.
They'd,
they'd tell you guys go,
what was the procedure like from there?
Uh,
assholes and elbows out to the aircraft.
The,
uh,
one of the other crews,
first,
first guy,
there would a be a suddenly,
uh,
the,
the aircraft was pretty cocked,
but they'd go ahead and,
uh,
set the uh,
the uh,
rockets up for us and uh,
jump in,
hit the button and go,
you,
uh,
every,
I think that it's safe to say that practically every operational mission that we
flew,
we took off over Max gross weight.
Uh,
you pulled it up enough to get it out of the revetment and get it out there.
What we do when we were really seriously overweight,
it just sort of inching ahead and get a little forward,
a momentum,
uh,
on the helicopter and then drop the collective,
which puts all the way down on the skids and spread the skids and then pop it up
a little.
And the aircraft would be s would sling shot up to oh,
about three feet and then,
you know,
yeah,
hopefully you'll get across the [inaudible] fence at the end of the end of the
runway.
It was colorful,
but had to do it in order to carry enough ordinance to,
uh,
to get it
guys out of trouble.
And then not,
I mean,
um,
when we were in Iraq,
we always felt like the helicopters,
which when Ramadi,
the helicopters,
they wouldn't really fly over the city of Ramadi cause it was,
it was too dangerous for them.
Um,
the couple times that they came in,
it was like a,
just massive machine gun fire at them and they didn't really enjoy that too
much.
But you guys were just so,
so my point is that helicopters and actually vehicles as well,
they're,
they're like bullet magnets,
right?
Everyone of you see a helicopter come in,
the enemy just sees that and focuses on it.
You guys must have be,
you had to be taken fire all the time.
Yeah.
All the time.
You get used to it.
The,
uh,
one of my gutters reminded me of a,
the first time that,
uh,
we saw a 51 cal coming at us.
It was a,
it was night.
And these things,
you know,
it's a big,
as a basketball,
it's as big as a freaking basketball coming up at ya
starting to see the tracers come up at it.
And he says,
Damn,
you did the right thing.
I said,
yeah.
And he says,
he lowered the collective immediately,
got down on the deck and then,
uh,
came around and we could,
could adjust.
But those things are frightening.
Oh yeah.
That's cool.
It's,
it goes with the turf.
You're,
you're,
you're 20 years old.
That was 23 at the time.
And
it's,
you think the mission,
you think the pride that you take in and the guys and the,
uh,
the,
the pride they take in you and it's frightening,
you know,
was there,
I was terrified at times.
I think we all were that,
uh,
you get by that you get by that you think about the guys down there who are
really in the ship and it's easy to,
uh,
apply what you know tactically and,
get the job done.
That's a,
that's another thing that,
that's why I was kind of asking you about meeting with the guys in the ground
because you guys are doing this and I'm sure in some situations you would never
met the people that were down there and you're still risking your lives to go in
there and give them the support that they need.
Yeah.
It's what we did.
There's a,
there's a counterintuitive thing to two helicopters that you just mentioned,
which is when you're getting shot at from the ground,
if you get lower,
it takes away some of their field of fire.
Right?
Right.
So,
so you would think,
oh,
there's someone shooting at me,
I'm going to get up and go away.
When the reality is if you get lower,
you know that that person's,
there's gonna be trees or whatever.
Yeah.
Terrain features in between.
That's of take a little bit of time to,
uh,
to get your instincts go to that direction.
Yeah.
It certainly does,
but it's amazing how quick those instincts are development.
When you got somebody shooting Mecha.
Uh,
and then the maintenance crews,
the birds,
I saw pictures of birds,
they were just like,
it looked like they'd been used for target practice.
Yeah.
Coming back,
you go watch that movie a scramble,
the seawall.
So it looks like target practice was used.
That's what they were using the boards for target practice.
That's what some of them look like.
And the maintenance crews would just,
they said they were making uh,
uh,
patches from beer cans.
That's true.
And they get,
the guys were proud of that.
And the,
uh,
the patch that,
was a beer cam would not be painted over generally.
Yeah.
Knowing that there was one thing that I want to say,
and then this is going to sound like I'm a one trick pony and my love for the
gunners.
Uh,
but those guys,
uh,
not only fired the weapons,
they service the weapons they serviced.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the helicopters,
they performed all the dailies.
They were all qualified plain captains.
They kept that thing up and running for us so that we could walk out with our
silk scarves and a strap the thing on and uh,
take them out to where they needed to be in order to get the job done.
No,
we're not air force.
We don't believe in silk scarves.
Sorry.
Air Force brethren.
And then not,
so you're,
you're doing this,
this is a crazy optempo operational tempo of 12 on 12 off 365 days.
Yeah,
that's insane.
You get used to it.
You know,
it's funny.
I mean,
you got it.
You got eight hours of sleep.
Okay.
And then you got four hours to eat and then the other 12 hours you're on standby
to go fly into,
into gun battles.
I got for 365 days.
Yeah.
I got nervous though when I wasn't flying.
You know,
a decent aviator wants to fly and uh,
it was hard.
Sometimes it's sitting around waiting for your turn.
We played,
lifted a lot of weight,
a plead a lot of volleyball for the,
played volleyball a with and against the,
uh,
the seals and sometimes the,
the boat drivers,
uh,
it just,
it was a 50 meters from the air from the aircraft.
And that kept us,
kept us right there so we could respond quickly.
And then,
um,
how often will you guys do in casualty evacuation?
Yes.
Only when needed.
Yeah.
It wasn't a primary mission of ours.
If somebody got shot up and a needed to lift out of town,
uh,
we provide that.
And occasionally we'd get a call that,
uh,
someone,
was a wounded and,
uh,
we'd go out and pick them up.
But generally that was a job that was done by some certifiable idiots that I
love.
The,
uh,
the dustoff pilots,
you've got to 20,
1920 year old kids that are out there given the keys to,
to a,
a,
a Maserati.
Chris,
this was only a Huey,
but still,
you get the idea.
They were crazy.
They'd fly into India.
Anything.
My hat really goes off to him because,
uh,
they'd fly into areas
where they shouldn't.
That's a,
another thing I talked about,
um,
with,
uh,
Colonel Bill reader who was on this podcast and same thing.
I mean he just said that the,
the pilots back then,
and maybe it's because the aircraft were a very inexpensive compared to the,
you know,
to what they fly nowadays.
They don't want to risk the aircraft now,
but he said he's got,
they would just fly into like,
it was a,
hey,
your,
your aircraft is just going to get hit.
That's the way it's going to be.
Yeah.
Deal with it.
And if you ever get the,
get the operator
Tunity to read,
uh,
the,
some of the,
uh,
citation for the congressional medal for the fees or Hilo pilots,
it's,
it's incredible what they did.
Now when I was an always on this show,
give the same praise that you give to the machine gunners because the machine
gunners in,
in a ground combat,
it's the machine gunners that are going to allow you to be able to maneuver and
get away from a situation.
Um,
or maneuver towards,
you know,
they're going to allow you to move.
And same thing with,
with your gunners and what they were doing.
So you had a gunner on each side.
That's right.
That would protect the flanks.
One of them on
either a 60 or a dual 60 and the other one on a 50 cal or in really corner.
Eventually a mini gun.
Oh,
and then you guys got the mini guns?
Yes,
I will.
I looked at there wasn't real a real fast flash on the screen in scramble to see
Wolfe's there's a mini gun and it's actually,
it's upside down.
You can't,
I had to pause it and to read it.
It said the Lord Giveth and the mini gun take away.
Yeah.
It was a formidable weapon for a close closer support.
For people that don't know what a mini gun is,
it fires.
It fires what?
5,000 rounds a minute.
I mean,
it's absolutely ridiculous.
What she hasn't sent it.
I don't know what the rate is,
but it's,
it gets your attention.
Yeah.
And it just,
it,
it's powered.
It's powered.
It's electrically powered.
So it,
it actually feeds the ammunition faster than,
than a,
than a normal mechanical weapon could fire.
But it just,
it's crazy how much,
how much,
how many rounds,
because I think it's 5,000,
something like that.
It's a ridiculous amount.
And then you guys got those.
So those were on your birds while you were on deployment?
That's right.
Yeah.
As far as the,
uh,
the mini gun goes,
you know,
it doesn't go bang,
Bang,
Bang.
It goes business at the rate of fire is phenomenal in the,
uh,
the gunners loved it.
But you know,
there's a little John Wayne and all of us and I think,
uh,
every one of them would like to go back to the,
to the free guns.
One thing,
uh,
that I,
I do want to point out is that,
uh,
we were not very well equipped.
So when we were up in around a,
you know,
on patrol or,
or,
uh,
actually out there engaged in,
had to fly into a tank of gas up and uh,
and uh,
uh,
rearm
we'd go into an army base because the army had all the fuel and they had nails.
The a 2.75 makes a boom,
but if you can load it with flush jets,
you can really keep the enemy down.
So we'd go on up there.
Uh,
depending on the tactical situation,
uh,
if,
if we had a cause,
a fair,
uh,
Eh,
anti personnel,
uh,
some something developing on the ground,
we'd,
uh,
we'd load up there.
And that's where I saw my first Cobra.
The snake was an impressive,
uh,
aircraft.
It was so much,
it had so much more fire power than any one of our Hueys.
But where do you put the gunners?
You know,
it's four and a half seating.
They don't have any suppression for rolling off target other than a,
your wing man.
And you know,
it was intriguing,
but it just didn't make sense to me there.
I remember this correctly,
that at one point you're whoever the commander was at the time got offered,
Hey,
do you guys want some cobras?
And the answer was no,
we,
we need to stick with the u s I'd heard that story.
I don't,
don't know whether it's true or not or,
yeah,
we'd like that.
But,
uh,
you know,
one of the guys you mentioned in the Wolfegram and I will mention his name.
Uh,
chuck steely,
uh,
object was quite a guy and he would go out,
on to requisition parts for us.
Uh,
at the time the army had a,
a contractor dine electron that was doing the,
uh,
the work on their aircraft and you know,
they're bored out of their skull when they don't have anything to work on.
So they,
uh,
got a,
a loach and started rebuilding it from spare parts from here and there and got
it to be fully functional and you know,
to have an observation helicopter like that,
uh,
to go out and a snoop and poop with us,
that would be incredible.
Chuck engineer to deal where for a refrigerator full of beer,
they'd give us this aircraft.
You know,
it was written off the uh,
roles there.
But uh,
you know,
they said,
hey,
if you have a problem,
let us know.
We'll come down and take care of it.
I,
I like to think that chuck was unplugging our refrigerator when the Deno and see
Amy again and not just no,
but hell no.
But that sort of thing was not unusual over there.
Yeah.
God Butts Chuck.
He did.
Did everybody a lot of great service.
The uh,
that speaking of beer,
apparently the,
the wolf on the Seawolf insignia somehow based on the low end brow beer can,
that's what they saw.
Allegedly.
That's what they say.
I can neither confirm nor deny.
You know,
strangely enough,
I didn't drink much beer at all when I was over there because uh,
uh,
the,
the seem to treat it with something that a,
just put the taste off.
We all thought it was formaldehyde.
That was the,
the,
the going rumor.
But when they told us that and go and I was in Guam,
my first deployment,
they told us the same thing.
Yeah.
That there was formaldehyde.
That rumor has been heard.
That rumor survived from 1969 to 1992 when I was on my first deployment,
there was formaldehyde in the beer.
But how did the beer tastes awful?
And I kept trying to see if I could make it taste better,
but I didn't succeed.
There's,
so some of the stuff that you're talking about,
um,
you know,
from a leadership perspective,
you got,
you got guys that are risking their lives every time that call comes.
How,
how did you,
did you see guys that got to a point where they couldn't take it anymore?
Did you,
did you have situations where you had to send guys back to the rear?
Um,
what did you do when you saw a guy kind of starting to start to get too nervous
to go,
uh,
this may sound self serving and I don't care.
I didn't see anyone in our debts and I did not see directly anyone who behaved
in a cowardly manner.
And overcautious manner.
Uh,
we didn't have anyone that,
uh,
was sent back to the,
to the rear.
Uh,
there was a comradery that you just can't explain to somebody who hasn't enjoyed
it.
It,
uh,
it's an honor to serve with people like that.
And we all took pride in our reputations among our,
uh,
our squadron mates.
So it wasn't hard at all.
And that was so clear when you watch scrambled to see Wolfe's.
It's so clear and there's this incredible,
um,
they,
you can see the comradery and you can hear it when you read through the,
the,
the wolf grams.
You can see that guys are having a good time.
And there's this,
I mean,
what I would consider,
and you can tell me if I'm wrong,
but like a peer pressure of,
hey,
we're gonna,
we're gonna do this.
You know,
I've,
I've often said that when you get to a good seal platoon is not a team.
It's not a platoon.
It's like a gang that makes a game and we just don't allow for that bad attitude
to creep out.
Yeah.
I feel the same way about the,
uh,
the Se wolfs and this might be a good time to share with you the fact that,
I,
at one time after a returning from Vietnam was so fed up with the mission that
we were flying.
It was an aging aircraft.
It didn't have systems that were required to do the job,
that the job itself was not that important.
And you know,
you come from living on adrenaline,
adrenaline for a year and then come back and uh,
you're expected to,
I dunno if I figure he really puts your,
a boots up on the table.
One day I got so pissed off in the middle of the morning,
I jumped in my corvette,
remember that maybe,
Hey,
I learned,
jumped in my corvette and a,
a tour on up to a corner auto.
And two of the seals that we operated with friends,
uh,
were there.
And I walked into the office.
They had their lsds pulled up face to face.
And I said,
guys,
I've had it.
I want to join up.
And they looked at each other and they locked up their secret.
And each of them grabbed me by an elbow and took me up to the little club in
Coronado.
And we started pounding beers that tasted great,
no formaldehyde there.
And by the middle of the afternoon,
they convinced me that,
uh,
being a,
a peace time seal,
uh,
wasn't,
everything that,
uh,
that I would expect.
And that,
uh,
the Navy had put an awful lot of investment into making me what I was and I
could make them far better contribution by continuing to fly.
And I,
uh,
I turned my back on my opportunity to find out whether I had what it takes to
become a seal.
I'm surprised that those guys,
um,
you're,
I'm surprised they didn't talk you into it.
Those must've been,
it must,
I'm strives once they got enough beer in them,
they did.
They didn't have you down at,
down at buds with the logo of the sand and over your head.
Is there any particular missions in when you were in Vietnam that,
that stand out as,
you know,
one of the ones on scramble and see,
we'll set,
they talked about this was absolutely ridiculous.
They're talking about the,
the,
the helicopter was there,
the helicopters were there supporting a unit on the ground.
There was no one to relieve him.
Um,
they needed more fuel.
They were running out of fuel.
The fuel lights on.
They're still no one to no one to relieve the helicopters and provide support.
They say,
you know what?
Screw it.
We're just going to stay until we run out of gas.
And that's,
and that's what they did.
They stayed until they ran out of gas.
The other group came in,
they used ammo cans to refuel,
to carry.
Once the,
once the fire on the ground had subsided,
they used ammo cans to refuel the,
the helicopters that were out of fuel so they could get back to base.
That's freaking crazy.
Well,
you know,
we never really took time to think about whether it was crazy.
You're not,
you've got a job to do and you know that that's probably a natural way to,
to explain it.
That was the job.
You went out and did that because that's what was expected.
That's what the guys on the,
in the boats expected of you.
That's what the cl team that we had a,
these are the seals that we had operated.
It had been luck expected and when they call you,
you go,
that's another thing I think is really,
um,
impressive about the Seawolf says,
well first of all they took volunteers to go do the job.
And uh,
and like you said,
a bunch of people volunteered.
But the other thing is,
and I heard some of the vets talking about this,
some of the seawall phets talking about the fact that they'd say,
oh,
I was in the navy and I was in the shit in Vietnam.
People say you were in the navy and you weren't in the shit.
But the reality is people,
you wouldn't,
I can't imagine that there was any of the gunners that when they join the navy,
they thought to themselves,
what I'm going to be is a door gunner in direct combat with the enemy.
These are guys that were joined the navy for whatever reason.
And they end up in that job where,
you know,
they're doing this day in,
day out and risking their life day in,
day out.
Not,
not really what they signed up for and yet they held the line over and over and
over again.
All of them.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it a ma,
it humbles me to have,
uh,
been able to,
a,
to operate with guys like that.
And you know,
I'd be
the pilots.
Yeah.
The pilot's a brass balls.
It was expected.
It was the job.
The gunners had those balls and then some,
because they kept us up and kept the aircraft up,
kept the systems up.
I had a leadership lesson,
uh,
when I first got there,
the grown up,
my dad,
uh,
you know,
he,
we hunt and fish and I,
uh,
had fired are we had to,
fourteens for each bird.
They hung on the back of the,
yeah.
Pilot's seat and I'd taken one on out.
We had a little makeshift range and fired it and brought it back on in after I
was done and took it in to the crew area to clean it.
You would have thought that I had just stepped on a baby rabbit.
I mean it was more,
it was polite,
it was respectful,
but give me that thing.
And the guys had that feeling about,
uh,
the armament,
you know,
it,
this,
this is my job,
I do this.
So,
you know,
it took a little getting used to,
it was easier to let them clean my 45
then,
uh,
I just kind of want to be,
you know,
when you're,
when you're there,
um,
you,
you start to get to know these guys really well.
I don't,
you didn't loot,
you didn't have anyone killed from your debt while you were there.
Is that correct?
That's correct.
But obviously other guys in other debts were killed while you were there.
Did you guys have any kind of,
and this is something I've talked about before is Americans and I think it's
just um,
cause we have so many different cultures here.
We don't have a good protocol to deal with to deal with death.
And you know,
other,
other cultures around the world.
If someone dies,
you know,
you,
you do this for a day,
you say this prayer,
you,
you go through the ceremony and then you move on.
And Americans,
we have so many different cultures here that are all mixed together.
And death isn't something that happens all the time.
So we really don't know.
A lot of times,
Hey,
what am I supposed to do?
And I think that's what,
that's what causes people problems is they don't know.
They don't know how to handle it.
They don't know how to put closure on it.
And so it just kind of sticks around.
When you guys would learn that,
that someone,
your debt had been killed,
was there any protocol that you guys set up?
Was there anything that you guys did too,
to try and take that on board and then move past it?
I probably
not on a leadership opportunity and when a guy's got killed,
uh,
and other debts in combat or even just a fairing and aircraft in for
maintenance,
uh,
I didn't sit down with the guys and talk about it.
I internalized it and being Irish,
uh,
could reflect on all the good times we had.
Didn't think about,
uh,
what,
what went wrong.
It didn't want to know initially,
you know,
eventually you do because it's important,
uh,
for,
for your trade that,
uh,
I just think about the good times that we,
we shared together.
I lost a couple of academy classmates.
I lost some great friends that I made while I was in country.
Uh,
when young fella,
and I don't want to mention any names,
but he and I were,
uh,
both,
bicyclists.
And the one thing that he wanted to do when he got back home was built himself,
the Primo bike and,
uh,
start,
start competing and he never got that opportunity.
And when you,
when you personalize something like that,
when you think about the opportunities that are lost in a heartbeat,
uh,
it makes you very thankful to be alive and makes you very thankful to have known
that person.
And it makes you feel like he should redouble your efforts to get the sons of
bitches that,
uh,
that took that life away from him.
It death,
you can help focus your aggression and that's a good thing.
Yeah,
no,
no doubt about it.
And that was,
um,
I guess my way,
again,
I was uneducated,
no one ever taught me,
but one thing I did is,
okay,
we're going to go to work.
That's the thing that I knew how to do.
That's what I still know how to do is like go to work.
And you know,
there's,
I guess you could say there's some,
uh,
you know,
eventually you gotta you gotta deal with it.
You got to feel it more in the future.
But man,
when I was overseas,
it's like,
yeah,
okay,
we're going to work.
And that's where the focus becomes because you know,
and also from my perspective was like,
you know,
your guys,
that's what they would want you to do.
That's what they would want you to do.
So
let me,
let me share something with you based upon what your guys would want you to do.
Came home from a mission,
uh,
one night we were in contact and you know,
you're,
you're decompressing and I walk up to my rack and there's this Manila envelope
for lieutenant JG rallies eyes only.
And I feel,
oh no,
somebody back on back home has died.
And I opened this thing up with trembling hands and pull it out and it's a
standard navy message.
And I said,
hi honey,
I'm going to be in a 10 minute,
uh,
in three days time.
Come on up and then see me.
Uh,
Shawn's mom felt the love of my life.
Call Sign Stinky.
It doesn't anything to do with the personal problems.
It's a matter of attitude.
Yeah.
She was a flight attendant for Braniff and she was flying to freedom birds in
and out and she had one coming in Ben Lux,
only about 40 click south of us.
I gone and okay.
And you know,
word immediately spread like wildfire throughout the debt.
And my God,
God bless them,
they slept in a son,
a sandbag bunker,
or enlisted a crew,
and it was normally pretty ripe,
but it was also the only place that was really a,
it had a little bit of privacy.
Well,
they had determined that I was going to bring stinking on down for lunch,
pick her up in Thompson Newton and bring her on down.
So they had that place spit shine.
I don't know how he'd be at if it was already it.
That turned out to be a bit of a disappointment.
We,
uh,
flew,
flew a helicopter on up to Thompson who,
and you know,
we're going over a bad guy country.
So,
uh,
it was armed and I land the thing in front of,
I had no,
I didn't land it,
I wasn't flying it.
Uh,
but we,
we landed in front of the,
uh,
the terminal if they're at a Thompson Hooten,
immediately this air force,
a truck comes on out with it's cherry job going.
And this,
uh,
the sergeant says,
you can't land here.
And I put it out to him that we already had and that we're just waiting for the
arrival.
And,
uh,
we solved the problem by saying,
listen,
this aircraft is armed.
Why don't you stay here and watch it for us and we'll just be a little while.
So we walked on over this big old green Braniff jet comes on in and everybody
gets off.
And,
you know,
the incoming guys aren't nearly as gay and festive is he outgoing guys.
So they get off in a,
there's Gail standing up at the top of the ladder just waving at me.
So it turns out she can't get off the aircraft,
but they didn't see anything about escalating on.
So,
uh,
you know,
my crew goes on up to the ladder and we're in there and Gail's introducing them
to the other stewardesses and they're loving it.
And,
uh,
we go to the back of the aircraft and sat there for 45 minutes just talking with
each other.
Uh,
but when we got back and Gail wasn't there,
the guys were just crest fallen.
They were so excited about having somebody there.
And you know,
I,
I don't think the place who has ever cleaned again,
but that was my experience with dating my hometown honey in the zone.
Yeah.
Did,
uh,
what was it like,
um,
was it standard Vietnam that were just replacements would come when it was time
for a guy to rotate out,
a new guy would show up?
Uh,
pretty much like I mentioned earlier,
I was Sorta Kinda drifted Dia Annapolis Hotel and happened to run into a guy,
weird Harold who you referenced in that Wolfegram.
Uh,
the,
uh,
came,
just walk them through,
uh,
with,
the,
uh,
debt for Omc,
a Colonel Hammond,
we called them a,
currently was a navy commander.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Dave introduced us and said,
hey,
this is a great guy.
We should have him.
And as it turns out,
they had an opening and,
uh,
within a matter of a few days I was in debt for,
so it,
it was sort of a roll your own environment.
Yeah.
You know,
obviously they put guys into,
into slots where they needed them,
but,
uh,
they think that tick was fluid.
So then not your time's coming up to,
to head home is it wasn't a one year,
365 days.
Yeah,
pretty much.
Yes.
And then did you,
you stayed right on doing your 12 on 12 off until it was time to go.
What they didn't normally do is for the last a week or two that you were in
country send you into a bend to it for the,
uh,
for the,
outprocessing and we'd fly with the c Lords.
So,
you know,
you didn't stop flying.
It was just a different mission and then you get back,
I then you,
then you get,
okay,
your time's up and it's time to go home.
Yeah,
pretty much.
Well,
you know,
there,
there'd be a little bit of a party.
I drunk acts,
but uh,
but other than that,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's,
that was,
that was it.
Then how was that transition going from Vietnam and then what,
how many,
how many hours later you're back in America or how many days?
Uh,
it was a,
he,
a street through shot.
We stopped off in Honolulu.
There was one other stop,
maybe Guam and then Honolulu and then home.
It does straight through and it's a way you,
so you were,
you married,
you weren't married yet?
No,
no.
We got engaged on R and R and a Hong Kong.
And that's a two beer story.
So you got R and r from Vietnam,
met your,
your bride to be in Hong Kong.
That's right.
And proposed a,
yeah,
the,
you know,
we'd already talked about it.
We knew it was coming there.
I got down on a knee and Jimmy's kitchen and all of a sudden it,
but it was pretty interesting.
Uh,
when I arrived in Hong Kong,
uh,
we were,
I booked a room at the Hilton,
so I go on down there and you know,
I'm checking in and I'm in my,
uh,
my uniform.
So the manager happens to be walking behind the desk and says,
ah,
Mr loudly,
Mrs Lolly is waiting for you in your room.
I forget.
Shit.
Gail's getting here to tomorrow.
What's mom going to think?
Well,
of course Gail had gotten in a day early.
She was in there lifting,
you know,
times were different back then.
So your transition from,
um,
from Vietnam back to America all of a sudden,
and you were,
you know,
people,
people use the term wild west sometimes to described various
military situations where it was,
whoa,
it was like the wild west.
I don't know if it gets much more wild west thing being Seawolf Vietnam I read,
it just doesn't seem the way you guys were running things the way the support
that you got or didn't get the,
I mean,
just the fact like you guys didn't even have flight suits.
They,
you had,
they wouldn't issue him or something like that and you guys were just wearing
kind of what you,
what,
what you could get ahold of.
Everything was sort of wild west.
It took longer to get into a flight suit than it did a pull on a nomex shurtain
certain bands.
And frequently it wasn't no Max.
And,
uh,
as they say a,
you know,
I've flown missions in my tenny runners,
just,
uh,
we'd leave our,
our gear there in the seat and if I was playing volleyball and,
uh,
they,
they scrambled us.
You don't think about anything but getting in that aircraft and getting it
crankin.
Hmm.
So yeah,
it was wild west.
Thank God.
Yeah.
And then,
and then you get back to America and you're still in the navy,
right?
Yeah.
How was that?
Well,
got through train,
you know,
first of all,
you're just decompressing now as a newly married a gal and her getting used to
living together.
Uh,
she's,
uh,
dealing with my unique personality and,
it was sort of a scramble.
We partied art.
So when we got back a couple of,
uh,
seals,
one of them had a,
um,
uh,
was connected to a family that owned one of the mansion's.
Uh,
they're in corn auto on the,
uh,
on the waterfront.
I think that was first street,
front street at any rate,
just to,
Oh man,
it was a beat up old place,
but it was truly a mansion.
And they had a couple of mattresses on the floor and they had a,
a table in the kitchen,
but Noah furniture and they had a tapper.
And we go over there and just party like crazy.
And the,
where I'm going with this story is through all of that time and through all the
craziness and through all of the drinking,
uh,
there was only one person who got hurt as a result of overindulging.
He a rift,
ran his car into a telephone pole,
didn't,
uh,
didn't kill him,
didn't even hurt him very much.
But that was the only instance that I know of.
And uh,
the only casualty we had to alcohol was that same guy who turned himself in,
uh,
to,
for Aa and a was a cashiered out of the navy.
And then,
uh,
for 10 years he was sober,
clean and sober,
and he applied to get back in.
And the Navy,
God,
love it,
let him back in.
But more remarkable than that.
This is one of our pilots now from a,
from a sea wolves.
Uh,
they gave him his wings back and he finished up his career flying.
Well,
that's awesome.
But the point is we,
we had a really great time when we got back and all that was sort of a haze,
but when I checked into the squadron after I completed the rag,
uh,
learn to fly the noble h three c slug.
Yeah.
Our commanding officer took me in and a,
in my checkerboard interview says,
I know where you've been.
I know what you've done.
You aren't going to get away with any of that crap here.
And that there was a leadership lesson there.
I knew that I never wanted to be like him.
That had to be intimidating for our guy though that's taken on these,
these pilots that have been doing what you had been doing and all of a sudden
they got to try and reign these guys back into the world.
Yeah.
I hope I'm not going into too many stories,
but a great friend about the only guy at names,
I'm using her guys who are deceased,
but at huge,
Candice was,
uh,
a copilot and a,
we were sent off to,
uh,
for,
to Guam for some,
a specialized training.
And he and I are there in our,
uh,
in our,
poopy suits at the bar,
the old club bar at the air force base on Guam.
And we're enjoying a couple of beers,
which tasted good.
And all of a sudden this metal rings like crazy and income.
These guys in,
in pressed flight suits with ascots and everybody in the bar,
all the air force guys are standing at attention.
This be 52 crew coming back from a mission.
And we're just sitting there with our elbows on the bar and the crowd didn't
know what to make of us,
but,
uh,
they didn't get too close to us either.
I mean,
come on.
We all have a mission to do.
And Rolling Thunder was a very important,
if a taken to,
it's a conclusion,
uh,
we might have not floss that war.
And I use the words loss and war carefully there and that,
that's not,
that's not a slip of the tongue.
Uh,
they've,
they've got a mission to do,
but I mean,
yeah,
the war from 40,000 feet and they're,
they're worried about Sam's because they turned in at this,
I don't want to go there.
I'm sorry.
I'd like to apologize to the United States air force and all the noble men and
women who fly for the air force.
Yeah,
that's a,
actually,
you know,
those,
um,
when,
when we got back from Ramadi,
we,
um,
we got after it in a very similar way,
for several months.
And I don't know how long you did,
but yeah,
there was a lot of,
uh,
um,
beer and other things that were drinking and I don't know,
you know,
there's,
it was sort of,
uh,
it seemed like the normal thing to do.
I don't know.
It seemed like we were going to kind
of get it out of our systems for a little while and you know,
um,
get over it.
Cause it is,
it is,
you know,
it's not that big of a deal.
I don't want to make it sound like it's all crazy,
but you know,
you're over there and it's like,
okay.
It's a little bit of,
it's,
it's a different,
it's a different scenario and you got to kind of process through the fact that
everything that you just were doing,
whatever,
a week ago,
two weeks ago,
three weeks ago,
is now completely different.
The way your life is completely different and there's no one's shooting at you
and there's no one not,
not,
you're not going to lose in your guys,
which was,
uh,
the weight that I felt lifted off of me about a month after I got home.
I was,
I just,
you know,
woke up one morning and I just kind of felt different and I kind of,
I was like,
why do I feel I felt different in a good way?
And what I felt was,
oh,
I was thinking about why do I feel different right now?
And as I sat there and thought about it,
it's like I'm not worried about any of my guys getting killed right now,
which was the first time in months that I hadn't been thinking about that all
day,
every day.
And so yeah,
when you come home,
um,
there's,
there's definitely that and I,
I think you,
I think you've got to pay attention to as a leader to everyone in that group to
make sure that guys are staying within the box and staying within what's,
what's,
I guess possibly normal for those situations because you can definitely be,
you can,
there'll definitely be individuals that they'll,
they'll,
they'll go too far that they're not making the transition and what they need is
some help someone to come alongside,
pull alongside and say,
hey man,
let's,
let's take it back a little bit were,
you know,
let's,
let's readjust and you know,
life's going to be normal again and all that.
Okay.
Unfortunately,
the way we were ruled in and out of the squadron when we left and came back to
the world,
it was pretty much an individual effort.
Yeah.
So that,
and I also tempered with the fact that your war was entirely different than
ours.
I would imagine.
Uh,
yours was more a up close in a personal than thinners that tell you the truth.
I don't recall ever reflecting on whether my guys we're going to come back from
this mission or not.
You know,
it's something that we just all did.
We all did it together.
And I don't mean that to sound callous.
It just wasn't part of my,
uh,
my thinking.
And that goes back to a what cousin Kim asked to,
you know,
how did you do it?
Yeah,
yeah.
Trying to bring everybody back hole.
Yeah.
I don't,
I definitely without question thought about that every,
every day.
That was the biggest thing that I thought about every day was because there was
guys getting killed every day,
basically.
Um,
there was a memorial services every day.
There was,
uh,
you know,
one of the,
one of the things that I've talked about this a bunch,
but there was a,
uh,
vehicle graveyard outside who wasn't,
it was on the way to the gate to leave Camp Rahmati there was a vehicle
graveyard where all the vehicles that had been blown up and destroyed by ids and
there was,
I would say 50 or 75,
maybe even a hundred,
but a massive area.
And so in order to leave the gate,
you drove by that,
you know,
it was a,
it was a pretty harsh reminder and you know,
my guys would go out and missions.
I wasn't always going on missions because I was overall in charge and there was
multiple units and um,
so a lot of times I'd be just salute and the guys as they'd be leaving and,
and that's a worst feeling of like,
okay,
you know,
you just,
you just got your damn fingers crossed and you hope you've done everything you
can and hope you've mitigated the risk.
But that was the heaviest.
The heaviest weight for me was just that daily thought.
Um,
every cause then there was also,
there was the fact that there was always guys in the field almost always.
So it was almost always one of my,
you know,
little detachments of guys was out there with seven guys and 20 Iraqi soldiers
and there was gun fights going on and,
and that's the way it was.
That was the,
that was the heaviest thing.
Um,
from a leadership perspective for me.
And yeah,
so when I got home it took about a month,
you know,
before I was like beef and,
and the,
the other thing is I didn't,
everything that I'm saying about that feeling,
I was barely conscious of it while I was there.
I was like,
it was there,
but I was more focused on doing the job.
I was more focused on,
it kind of cooked me like,
you know,
when they say the frog or we put the frog in the boiling water,
you cook it slow whenever you,
there was like that.
It was more like that,
like over time it just built up.
And what I did was just focused on work and working hard.
But then when I got home,
it was like I said,
it was like a month after I got home,
I woke up one day and just felt like,
uh,
a weight lifted.
And I was saying,
why do I have,
what is that?
What is that?
And then as I thought about it,
I'm thinking,
what am I not,
why do I feel like this?
You know,
I just had a big smile on my face and was,
you know,
walking around my house and thinking to myself,
wow,
this feels good.
What is this?
And then I realized,
Oh,
you're,
you're actually not worried that one of your friends is going to die today,
which is,
uh,
which was,
a totally,
it's like I said,
it was something that crept up on me and was just there.
It was just part of being over there.
And,
um,
it felt good to,
uh,
to,
to have that weight come off.
But,
um,
you know,
again,
I think I dealt with it pretty decently and,
you know,
did I get drunk with my friends?
Yeah.
Well,
there was,
uh,
some,
some significant to you bruiser activities that,
um,
or were,
were fun and we let off a lot of steam.
Yeah.
And I think that's fine.
But again,
you know what worries me about saying that is that there's some people that take
that as like,
oh,
okay,
now I'm cleared hot just to go and,
and get drunk and get crazy.
And it's like,
no,
actually you're not.
Um,
you got to keep that in check in,
especially from the guys that are in leadership positions.
Hey man,
you gotta keep a close eye and step back and detach and look at the guys and
say,
okay,
I get it.
We're going to let off some steam.
We're going to adjust back to the real world,
but we need to make sure that everyone is staying inside the box and make sure
that they're going to come back out of this thing.
Okay.
Because I mean,
we all know it nowadays,
man,
the vets veterans come home.
And that's a hard transition to make from,
from combat to the civilian world.
And,
and,
and even the world that you're talking about going from being a seawall from the
wild west,
coming back to your commanding officer saying,
look,
you're not going to get away with that crap here.
And you know,
we,
we definitely had our share of little stories like that from two bruiser where,
you know,
guys guys would not quite be ready.
And you know,
as a matter of fact,
JP Danelle who is with me at echelon front,
w my brother,
when he came home,
when we came home,
he was in another platoon got hurt.
They send them to our basic training school.
So Bud's,
he's going to be a bug's instructor and he didn't last very long over there
because you can't take a guy that's 23 years old that just been through what JP
had been through and say,
okay,
now you're going to go,
go and be in charge of training these guys that are trying to make it through
buds.
It,
it wasn't a good fit.
And so I just,
you know,
luckily I had friends and was able to just pull him over and he worked directly
for me.
Again,
getting guys ready for the more advanced training in combat training,
which she was perfect for.
But that was an example of where,
you know,
I was,
I had to look out and say,
okay,
this is not a good job for him.
It right now,
you know,
JP is already an intense,
an intense guy and coming home from Ramadi,
you know,
it was,
it was a,
it was a tough deployment.
You only lost friends.
And as a young kid,
he wasn't ready to be teaching these young,
you know,
he's looking at these kids like,
are you kidding me?
I'm going to,
I'm going to freaking decimate you guys.
And so I had to pull them over to a little bit more advanced mastering my
brother.
Jfe um,
so you get,
oh,
so now,
so now you,
you're staying in the navy.
That's it never a doubt in my mind.
And you end up,
I mean,
you,
you ended up doing the anti submarine warfare,
which is the job that kind of,
is that the job that annoyed you?
Uh,
we called it also what
we were given a mission without the,
uh,
the means to prosecute the mission and the,
that annoyed me.
And then,
and then you went on to become a test pilot.
Is that right?
Is that correct?
Steely-Eyed Granite Jod test pilot and look at me now.
So,
so what does that job like?
Ah,
it's,
it's fascinating me.
You know,
I'm living proof that nothing harms or that person more than too much formal
education,
but I get off on that and uh,
it was brought home to me once when we were having a raging party at her home in
protection river,
Maryland when I was there at the tow center and most of the guys would have a
copy of playboy magazine on their night table.
A couple of the guys had gone back to take a leak in our bedroom and found that
I had some technical reports.
They're
mine.
And I didn't hear the end of that for a,
for a long time,
but I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed the,
the technical aspects of it.
I
often said there are only two topics that are worthy of conversation between men
and that is flying and fornication.
And
I lived to fly.
Having said that,
since I retired,
I've found very little,
but at that point in my life it was all about flying.
And uh,
it was a wonderful experience.
The,
the flying we did was not experimental flying.
It was engineering flying.
We test out weapons systems,
we test out new aircraft.
I was fortunate to,
uh,
to,
lead one of the three prongs of the,
uh,
the biggest helicopter acquisition that the navy's made when they were looking
for the new lamps helicopter.
Uh,
two of my great good friends,
we're,
uh,
we're flying the a Sikorsky and the,
and the,
uh,
Boeing products.
And they were pretty well through their test program,
which took I think about a year when a bell helicopter piped up and says,
Hey,
we've got one,
two,
well they didn't have a,
uh,
a really logical contender,
but they needed somebody to go on down and leave the test of that aircraft.
And that was me and boy,
that was fun.
You know,
you literally are flying to test card that takes you out to the edge of the
envelope and then,
hey,
you're,
you're good enough.
Sure.
I'm good enough.
Yeah,
just uh,
uh,
don't go too far and don't bust your ass.
Here's,
there's a lot of investment that you're sitting in right there that you want,
they want you to keep in,
in one piece.
But no,
I thoroughly enjoyed it.
A lifelong friends there and
just keep me to a story.
The two guys that were flying a,
the Boeing's and Sikorsky dear friends,
one of them was a naval academy classmate and he and I flew in Vietnam and uh,
the other guy,
Greek is just a wonderful guy and still a lifelong close friend.
Well,
a duck,
uh,
was unfortunately,
he,
fortunately for Hughes became their chief test pilot.
Uh,
he got out of the navy and was a flying for Hughes and was killed in a,
in a,
in a horrible,
a accident and Greek and I sorta sorta closed ranks and,
uh,
decided that,
we were going to try and send a duck off in good stead.
So
if you're familiar with San Diego,
now,
you know about the point Luma Lighthouse in the area up there,
that's where the family was waiting.
Hughes had given us a,
a 500 to a scatter.
The remains in a Greek,
took it himself to do this.
Now at this time,
he probably had a 2,500 flight hours.
He knew his way around a helicopter.
He's in his navy blues.
He gets in the aircraft,
he's got the Cree mains in his lap and they're flying out along well below,
uh,
the,
the point on,
on out over the ocean.
And he looks up and sees the family up there and he's so emotionally rocked that
he reaches down and takes the lid off of the [inaudible].
Well,
if you've ever been in a helicopter,
you know that it's not a very stable place to have Cree mains.
And immediately he said it was ifr inside that cockpit with duck every way.
And fortunately the family didn't know what was going on and everything came out
fine.
But Greek could call me up and said,
hey,
I had to had to make mustard today.
And I said,
yeah.
And he says,
yeah,
and when I got my blues out,
I'm still brushing duck off.
So yeah.
There's ways you a you accommodate that?
Uh,
I,
I always think of the great good times that a duck in Greek and I had together
and I miss him.
Sure.
I miss him all the time.
But life goes on.
It sounds like he had the final say it that way.
Yeah.
You were OIC during the Iranian hostage crisis.
What was that like?
Uh,
that,
uh,
was self made,
you know?
Yes.
We were the only a,
a helicopter out there that wasn't on the large gray boats to actually fly the
mission that,
uh,
could,
could provide a combat search and rescue.
Uh,
so,
uh,
we took full advantage of that.
Uh,
got the armament that we thought we passing through Guam.
I took like the side arm I had,
so I went on down to buy one and know it's going to take two weeks and it took
me about two hours to get in touch with the local authorities.
And I had my,
uh,
my sidearm on going over the horizon,
which is sort of silly,
you know what I mean?
Really,
you're flying and overwater mission and you need,
he said,
well,
you never can tell.
It's always good to be prepared,
but uh,
at any rate,
we did go out there and uh,
and just train for that,
uh,
when we weren't actually out there in support of the,
the boats we can train for that.
You end up doing your 20 years.
Um,
and then you called it at 20,
because that does,
how long you did,
20,
21,
21 years.
And then you went off to the civilian sector.
Yes,
we did.
Started working a bunch of various jobs.
That's right.
I started out in high tech.
Uh,
our company had a,
a professional staff of 260% of whom were,
and I had enough technical background that,
uh,
I'd go out to a customer with one or more of these PhDs and they'd make their
presentation.
And I'd say,
let me think what the doctor meant to say was,
I just had it had a greater being surrounded by smart people.
It just is a lot of fun.
It can be very frustrating at times,
but it's a lot of fun.
Yeah.
And we have a,
a curious insult in the teams,
which is someone will ask you about a guy and the guy's not a bad guy,
but someone will say,
well,
you know,
he's,
he's a real,
he's a really smart guy.
You know,
you might not be the best,
most common sense.
He might not be the best leader,
but you know,
he says,
you know,
he's a smart guy.
So yes,
it can get frustrating.
Hang around with people that are super smart and then find,
and when did you move to Hawaii?
Oh,
about 14 years ago.
I spent five years in a range operations and then they created a new position.
And for my last five years,
I was the environmental manager for the Pacific muscle range.
My,
uh,
daughter,
when she learned that said,
dad,
you hate those guys.
And I said,
yes,
Heather.
But no,
I'm in a position to say no.
And I just had a lot of fun,
you know,
the,
the video,
the local environment and coming community,
great people.
But,
uh,
they were not strong supporters of military training and that,
that was uh,
my cause to help them explain why we needed to,
to train out there and that we've heard out to kill the whales.
Yeah.
Are,
yeah.
Um,
and then how long ago was it that you retired?
Retired.
About four years ago.
That's
retirement has been very,
very good to Dj.
And,
uh,
I mean I got,
I got one more quote that I,
that I,
that I wanted to read.
Um,
cause I know we've been going at it for a bit here,
but,
uh,
this is another quote.
This is a quote from,
um,
from a Vietnam seal.
Um,
and here we go.
Not only does many a seal always life to the sea wolves,
but the units often operated together as a team very often located at the same
base of operations.
We developed friendships that are still alive today,
operating well outside standing opera standard operating procedures.
The Seawolf Sev lifted seals out of enemy and circle moments and I have known
them to land in a hot Lz to lift out cash is too large for the seals to pack
out.
They also evacuated our wounded when medivac helicopters were not available.
Most important,
they were always there for us when we were down in the mud and darkness.
The night illuminated with red and green tracers,
the VC behind every shadow.
Many times after we were out of danger,
they stayed with us until we were safely extracted in the middle of the river
and out of the range of enemy fire.
And that's chief Barry Easyknock,
who's a
legendary seal from seal team one navy cross recipient.
And I think that that quote just really exemplifies the,
the bond between seals and sea Wolfson.
Like I said,
it was something that I heard about as a young seal and it's a bond that still
exists.
When a,
when I talked to the Vietnam seals and it's a bond that's,
uh,
that's always going to be there.
And,
um,
oh,
Amanda,
that,
uh,
do you have any,
you know,
I,
like I said,
we've been at it for a while and I like,
and like I told you before we started,
I can sit,
I'll sit here,
I could sit here and listen to you all day,
but uh,
do you have any other,
you know,
any other closing thoughts that you want to,
that you want to mention?
Uh,
hand salute to the 44 that didn't make it back with us.
anyone who hasn't been to the wall,
anybody who's served,
who hasn't been to the wall,
you've got to make that trip and
a shout out again.
And I know it sounds like a broken record,
but to the guys that were responsible for getting me back in one piece or
gunners great human beings and a to the guys I flew with,
hey,
next time we'd get together the beers on you.
Yeah,
I should share with you that,
uh,
as a technical person,
I have developed what I call rallies,
theorem and rallies.
Theorem says that all the truly great ladies Hook up with all the truly big
buffoons and stinky if you're out there listening,
I sure am glad that you did that.
Love you more than pork chops baby.
And uh,
we're also thanks to your son Sean for,
uh,
for connecting us.
And then when he came up and asked me,
he's like,
Oh,
do you,
would you have a sea wolf on your podcast?
I'm like,
ah,
let me think about that for 0.2 seconds.
Absolutely.
So,
um,
yeah,
thanks to Sean for connecting us and,
and it's,
it's been an honor to sit here and listen to you and thanks for what you and all
the sea wolves did for our country,
for our navy.
And specifically,
thank you for the support that you and your brothers gave to my brothers and my
forefathers on the ground in Vietnam.
Will never forget what you and your brothers did.
I will never forget the sacrifices of those,
those Braves,
he wolfs that made the ultimate sacrifice for our freedom.
Oh Man.
And Dennis Rally has,
has left the building and obviously awesome to have him on and incredible
opportunity to talk about this,
the sea wolves and go check out this website.
It's seawolf.org really cool website to read through.
One of the coolest things on it is I read that example of the wolf gram.
They got all the wolf grants and they're all just 40.
They're good,
they're worth checking out.
They've also got all the awards that well not they've got the list of the wards
where they got the navy cross awards and there,
uh,
just an awesome website.
So go check it out.
See wolf.org
and with that,
if you want to support,
you know yourself,
this podcast,
et Cetera,
echo,
what do you got?
Stay on the path.
Okay.
It's been a path to talk about Jujitsu.
Yes.
Did you get to
get a g?
We know we're getting gies origin youth.
Do we all know that yet?
That's origin.
Do we know that?
Yes.
You should go to origin main.com that's where you get your geek and rash guards
for Jujitsu.
Hundred percent bar none.
I'm almost tempted to say don't even get any other kind of or rash card.
I would agree with that.
Yeah,
boom.
Hundred percent.
Also,
if you're warming up or cooling down or just cruising,
they have joggers and you got into the joggers.
My son got some of the joggers,
which he's totally stoked on.
I tried them on.
Yeah,
just to see.
It was so horrible.
They are so not,
not,
not use situation.
Well,
here's the thing with joggers,
depending on how you wear them for sure,
but they're more of a,
um,
should I put this Kinda acceptably?
They're kind of form feeding from time to time.
Right?
So they're,
you know,
they kind of,
so they don't flap around.
So they're form fitting you in form fitting joggers.
Yeah,
I could see how that could be a violation for sure.
But if you're not Jocko joggers,
most comfortable joggers in the world,
probably in the history of joggers,
maybe ever origin mean origin joggers.
Also we've got some supplements on there,
um,
that you can take.
You got joint warfare,
which will keep your joints intact.
Yeah.
Krill oil,
same thing.
Kinda universal
substance.
Yeah.
That's to maintain the joy.
I went off the joint warfare for a little while.
Why?
Wow.
Long Story.
Yeah,
I did,
you know,
lapse of discipline and Holly kind where I'm like,
oh,
I don't feel the pain,
you know,
or nothing.
So I just don't,
I'm not like compelled as much.
You make it like a routine though,
right?
It's like,
that's just the thing.
I get up every day.
You take it before I get,
I take her loyal and,
and joint warfare.
When I wake up in the morning and before I go to bed at night,
period into story every day.
Still the a hundred percent do you want a during that day?
But yeah.
Well,
discipline is not 100% because I don't take that every day.
I take it when needed.
Yeah.
But I will say I've been using,
I feel like that's a little bit of a crutch right now cause I've been using it a
lot before.
You can take it every day.
But no,
the joint warfare I eat.
Like your mindset.
I think I actually,
I think I should incorporate that where it's just every day.
So with joint warfare I'll be like,
well,
you know,
like it'll be in my mind,
not even necessarily heavily,
but it will be on my mind.
Oh,
did I train hard enough to warrant joint warfare?
Kind of kind of attitude.
It's more or less like that.
So I wasn't feeling any kind of inflammation or pain or nothing.
So I was like,
ah,
you know,
it's like,
so I skipped it one day and then I sorta,
you know,
it just wasn't in my mind.
Sure enough.
And I'm still lifting,
still twin it,
it's still in the game.
Fricking elbow comes back because I'd get elbow from uniform pressing,
you know,
and I get little elbow things.
Nothing terrible.
You just got to warm up more or whatever.
But man it came back and not just like,
Oh let's try it 100% then was just,
this was just the other day,
so usually it takes a few days to like kind of get back.
How's it feeling right now?
That's fine,
but when I started,
if I started to do a pushup,
like a close grip pushup right now I'll feel it.
Probably.
Maybe it won't,
I don't know cause it's been a few days,
so that's joint warfare,
Krill oil discipline and then got milk,
which is just the food that you need in your body.
That's what it basically is and it tastes good.
And also for your kids you got warrior,
kid milk,
strawberry and chocolate.
They're both really good,
but let's face it,
the strawberry is a whole nother deal.
Brian is working on adult strawberry milk will be coming out with that.
Can I ask you this about the regular milk?
Dark chocolate is good,
right?
You get after a certain number of,
what is it?
What is it?
What makes dark chocolate better?
Right.
It's like a certain percentage of
life.
Yeah.
Cause there's no sugar in it.
If you just get straight dark chocolate,
right.
But then there's this 80% 80% that's like the threshold.
Let me read you this way.
80% is good.
When you get to 72% you're like,
you're like,
oh that's just a tasty,
you know,
you're just eating dessert.
Yeah.
80% is not quite,
it still gives you a chocolate satisfaction,
but it's not like the same.
Let me Redo this way.
If you eat two squares of 80% chocolate,
you won't desire more.
If you eat to eat to scores of 72% chocolate,
you like to have a little bit more cause it just like that.
Tasty.
Okay,
perfect.
So,
so the uh,
the milk with adult milk,
my question to you,
in your opinion,
your Jocko discipline opinion,
if I put a chunk,
because last night I've put this chunk,
there's this chunk.
I don't know why he was there.
It was their chunk of chocolate.
It wasn't 80% in the blender.
I didn't put the whole thing.
I broke off a little piece.
So it was maybe like the size of a uh,
to,
you know,
the little baby snickers bars.
Two of those I would say that's how big the chunk,
this block of chocolate to the baby's snickers.
Yeah,
it was pretty big.
It was a big monk shake though.
It's like three scoops,
you know like the,
you know,
the 30 ounce mugs that we have full anyway,
put it in with a peanut butter chocolate milk and it enhanced it.
Oh yeah.
Well of course you saw her in Paris.
So the question is,
is like how much of a violate,
like if it's 80% chocolate,
dark,
80% dark chocolate or you didn't put any
sugar chocolate or the matter what I did,
I didn't do,
I'm saying theoretically if I did 80% or more chocolate,
that's good.
That's still within the confines of being on the path in the game.
You're in the game and on the path.
Okay.
80% so if when we come across 80% chocolate,
let's add that just collectively,
let's add that and see how we all feel about that.
That's what I think.
You get the little chips at the bottom of the cup too.
It's pretty cool.
Check.
Also,
I just talked to a guy who strawberry or for the warrior Kid Moke if your kid is
lactose intolerant you put them on the almond milk.
Right.
So get some of that to get also if you want to represent on the path
jock was a store,
it's called Jocko storms where he can get shirts,
hats,
hoodies,
tank tops,
more rash guards recommended still within within the confines of being in the
game or rash guards as well.
Uh,
if yeah,
if you want to represent in the wild on the path and in the
wild@thesametimejockostore.com.
That's where you can get some cool stuff.
All Jocko approved all of it women stuff on there is by the way there is
counterfeit Jocko stuff.
Yeah.
But here's the thing about the conch fit.
Here's the thing about the counterfeit ones.
They're like obviously like if you,
all you have to do here,
I dig it like you'll see a cool design that seems new.
Cause that's really the,
the,
what do you call it?
The visceral visceral that's negative,
right?
Like your immediate responses,
like Oh,
new design on Amazon or wherever these counterfeits exist,
you see the new design.
So you kind of,
Oh cool.
And you're in your,
in your haste,
you click on it.
But here's the thing,
if you just stop for one second,
you can be aggressive but not foolhardy,
right?
That's the deal.
So you take this one moment to recognize the design.
You'll know there's violations all through every single design on there.
First off,
the font is the completely wrong fun.
It's completely wrong.
Then I saw one like the good one,
right?
That's on like you know one of these,
one of these websites that you can go to and you submit your pdf or jpeg and it
generates a shirt for you.
It's like it's a super cheap thing.
So there's one of those,
I forget what it's called,
but it's one of those where it's like obviously cheap and the design is wrong.
It's backwards.
Ours is backwards.
The good sits is backwards.
It's how it's supposed to be.
There's ones all frontwards,
like just some person who didn't pay attention is trying to do it.
It's real obvious if you take that second to notice it though.
So the counterfeit ones,
you know they're young.
Sorry,
just to look out for the counterfeit ones.
Yeah,
they're out there also.
Do you won't get counterfeit ones add chocolate store.com correct?
Yes.
Actually.
Factually.
Um,
also Jocko white tea.
Is there a counterfeit Jocko white tea?
Yeah.
That one's going to be a lot harder to counterfeit.
You'd have to put some effort into that one.
Yeah.
You'd have to get labels.
I would actually be kind of impressed like slightly just in your mode of getting
after it.
Would it be high level because it's not easy to make tea.
No,
not easy to make cans of tea.
and it's not easy to deadlift 8,000 pounds unless you've been drinking your tea,
so it get some of that organic too,
by the way,
certified.
Just saying.
Also subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already on iTunes and stitcher and
Google play and wherever he listened to a podcast because there's a lot of
podcast apps.
There's a lot of podcasts too.
Yeah.
And if you're listening to this one tank,
in a way it's kind of like,
man,
thanks.
We'll definitely thinks there's also the warrior kid podcast,
which is getting a lot of hype right now.
Yeah.
Why?
Because we talked about it on the last two podcasts.
Go here.
People kind of recognized and they didn't.
This is the thing,
I'm not real good at the whole like,
uh,
like,
hey everyone,
I look at what I'm doing that's not really sure.
You know,
I'm like,
Hey,
here's a podcast.
If you want to check it out,
check it out.
So with the,
I posted it and talked about it and so a bunch of people went and checked out
the warrior could podcast.
The feedback is awesome and I appreciate it.
And also if you want to check out some warrior kids' stuff,
you can check out Irish oaks ranch.com where Aiden,
who's a warrior kid is making soap on his farm just for real.
And if you want to get some of that soap,
Irish oaks,
ranch.com that way you can follow the motto of Aiden's soap and that motto is
stay clean.
So check that one out.
Also,
we've got a youtube channel,
which is called Jocko podcast,
and that's where these videos are of this podcast.
If you want to see what Dennis rally looks like,
how tall,
how tall he is.
Can you tell that from a where he's sitting down,
he was kind of going out of frame,
like sit up.
Yes.
So yes,
he's,
yeah,
he's a big dude full of Aloha by the way.
Wasteful of a law.
But yeah,
if you want to see what what Dennis Rally looks like and you can come on there,
you can also see echoes enhanced videos as he likes to call them.
He thinks it's an enhancement when he adds stuff to them.
Do you think it takes it away?
I didn't want it takes away from the message all message.
Just I've heard that.
Yeah that people have actually told you that.
Well I don't agree with it.
Totally changed.
My attitude is the,
is the Mike and the dragon,
the video,
that video is sick.
The video that you made is sick.
Cool.
And that video,
I said to myself,
even this is more powerful.
Even like,
you know,
you never really think about what you think about it but like the background
music,
like when when it says the king dies and then it's like cello kicks it in the
background.
I'm like
yeah,
well that that is a good point.
And you are kind of advanced in your thinking because re to put kind of to put
it kind of precisely,
the goal is it's not necessarily to be like,
hey what's the background music supposed to be?
It's like what's the feeling supposed to be?
And then you know,
certain instruments for music or whatever,
we'll provide certain feelings and you know,
that's kind of look old to line them up.
That's it man.
You recognize that.
So that video has definitely impressed upon me that videos can have a positive
impact and positively enhance to use your term,
what's going on with the words that are in the video.
Yeah,
but what about if I put like the walls crumbling and crashing down c and you
just do that over again,
it happens.
Explodes that.
Does that take away from her?
Like one of those people that got carried away with CGI on that video,
which I,
you know,
you've got to explore the boundaries.
Yes.
And sometimes you go out to sea.
On a recent video that I did,
I'm not going to say which one,
but I did the same thing,
but now with crumbling and crashing noises and effects,
I did it with lens flares.
Lens flares,
right?
Oh yeah.
Somebody like go lens flare.
Somebody puts a light in front of the camera.
Yeah.
Well it's the aberrations or I dunno,
whatever the word you want to use that that a light going directly at the
camera.
We'll create these lectures and you can do it on purpose.
Right?
It's like a look.
It's like an epic look when you get what's called an anamorphic Lens.
It kind of does this thing,
it compresses it to the set kind of thing.
And then when you,
when you to put in layman's terms,
basically when you put the video,
did you do this on,
I can't tell you now I'm going to go watch all my videos,
go watch all the videos you tell me.
But here's why I don't want to say it.
Because now people will be paying attention to it and they'll be like,
okay,
not to go into a whole long thing,
but okay.
So there's a guy named Jj Abrams,
he's a director and I think a writer too.
But anyway,
he does,
he did like the new star trek movies.
He did the new star,
you know,
he's like kind of a Scifi guy.
Um,
and he got a lot us,
he got a lot,
people had an issue with the amount of lens flares he allowed in star trek,
the newer stuff.
So Claire,
everywhere I caught her look dope man.
I really liked that look.
But he got a lot of,
you know,
a lot of shit for it.
Nonetheless,
I don't want to be in that same boat with these videos,
with that particular video that I'm talking about,
so if they don't notice,
then good.
If so and that,
see what I'm saying?
I'm going to go post about it.
Nonetheless.
Psychological warfare too,
which is an album of tracks where I tell you what you should do to push through
the moment of weakness and that's all we're going to say about that.
Okay.
It works with 100% certainty.
I'll add that.
Are you still batting 100% right now?
I'm going to call.
I'm going to call you on that.
Oh,
100% every single time I've ever used.
The other thing,
I haven't used it recently because it's like,
are you scared of it?
I didn't.
I knew need it.
I don't have many moments.
Weakness nowadays.
See,
I'm like forged in the fire of discipline.
No transgressions.
Are you trying to set yourself up to make a video with flair for yourself?
No.
No,
no.
I'm reporting back to you.
My current status on my discipline and the less,
I haven't had to use it recently.
So yeah,
I mean it doesn't matter if every single time that I've used it it.
Yeah,
it helps.
Like what I'm going to do,
listen to you telling me and then like I'm stoked to me just making the effort
to open my ears to you is already you already like on the way to like power
through.
Yeah,
exactly right.
Check.
So you know 100% on that one.
In my experience.
Also you want to vary up your workout on it.
Fitness gear,
is that on [inaudible] dot com they've got a lot of cool stuff on there,
a lot of good stuff.
So if you want to improve,
enhance,
very increased variables,
increased stuff in your workout.
If it's getting boring or something like this,
go to [inaudible] dot com get some,
get something from there like kettlebells or rings or battle ropes.
I think if you add one or more of those things into your workout,
it will be enhanced greatly.
Results wise.
It's my opinion.
Prediction.
Also books.
What do we got?
Well,
first of all,
we've got Mike in the dragons,
told you about the video,
go watch the video and then you'll want to get the book.
Why?
Because Echo did a really good job at and things because the book is legit.
Am I love to say that about my own or that make me arrogant
from that again told it's legit.
Everyone appreciates it.
And a bunch of people have now started posting reviews on Amazon,
which is very cool.
I appreciate it.
I read them and I'll read some next time live.
But uh,
yeah,
so,
so Mike and the dragons,
here's the deal.
Is
it sold out at this moment in time?
Yes.
Will it be sold out when you hear this?
Probably not.
Actually.
It's probably,
we got more books coming in.
I'm getting them printed,
um,
as quickly as they can possibly print them.
And I apologize for not correctly estimating how many books everyone would buy.
That is my fault and I apologize for it.
But if you do want Mikey and the dragons,
order it as soon as you can so that you can get it as quickly as possible.
Also the way the warrior kid books where the warrior kid and Mark's mission,
those books are good for kids and adults and really anyone and you know just got
done talking to talking to Dennis rally downstairs and he's like Oh yeah I read
those books.
They're awesome.
So he's a,
he's a what are,
I don't know how old he is but he's a Vietnam veteran pilot and he read or your
kids and was was down for the cost.
That's weird.
You sit down for the cause cause I was thinking in my head down for the car.
Well he is clearly down for the cost discipline equals freedom field manual.
Good one.
Outstanding one acts really I think so.
Again,
and I said this before,
I'll say it again because this is a constant thing.
It's like one of those things like a manual,
like an actual manual for life.
Right.
But so okay you said that I get it but yeah you refer to it.
That's what you do.
It's like a reminder and we do this all the time by the way.
But this is a good one to just remember cause that's part of the,
the the,
actually it's the majority of the challenge right there.
It's to remember this stuff like say hey,
you shouldn't freaking drink a soda right now with your Sushi.
Don't do that.
You know that already.
But if it's just part of the habit,
it's like boom.
You might forget because you were thinking about some other stuff,
you know,
some edits or whatever that you had to do saying so he got that manual.
They're this time and you just refer to it kind of made me even daily.
Semi daily.
I recommend daily.
Daily.
Yeah.
And you just remember all this stuff just keeps you on the path,
man.
That one is in print by the way.
There's plenty of them so you can order that one.
And that's a good Christmas gift.
Yeah.
For people that you know who needs it in your world.
You know what I mean?
And I don't think it's insulting by the way.
If someone is offended by it,
just get them to crack it open cause they'll realize like,
hey,
this isn't meant to offend.
This is meant to build.
Yeah.
And actually you know what,
now that you think of it,
that book isn't like extreme ownership might be that kind of book that if you
get it with some,
for someone they'll be like,
like what are you should you know,
like will elicit a,
what they call defensiveness.
But the field manual won't cause like first when you first see it you're like,
oh this is awesome item.
See what I'm saying?
Like looking at it.
But it's like,
yeah,
it's like a cool like field manual.
It doesn't scream like you need to take responsibility for stuff.
That's why I'm getting it.
Just you get that feel.
But even if even if that person might feel that maybe you got to do it with like
a certain type of card or something seems saying,
yeah.
Thank you for everything you've ever taught me.
And then like give it to them.
See what I'm saying?
Well,
speaking of extreme ownership,
there's extreme ownership and there's the dichotomy of leadership,
both books that are about leadership and they are available of course.
And those are,
those are books that will pragmatically teach you how to lead.
That's all there is to it.
Uh,
echelon front.
Speaking of leadership,
that's our leadership consultancy.
We solve problems through leadership.
It's me,
Leif,
Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran,
Mike's Riley and Mike by FEMA.
Go to echelon front.com.
If you want us to come to your business and align your leadership or you want us
to come and do a keynote speech,
go to echelon front.com and get the details there.
The muster is coming up 2019 video,
soon to be released.
Yeah,
it's going to be in Chicago,
Denver End.
Sydney.
Yes.
Three months to Sydney,
Australia.
Are you familiar with that area?
Yeah.
So Chicago,
Sydney and Denver,
checkout extreme ownership.com.
That's where we'll post the details.
All of them have sold out
and all of them will sell out.
You might not think that in Australia we're going to sell out,
but we will.
So you've seen all of them have sold out in the past?
In the past,
yes.
Sorry,
sorry.
Yes,
they have.
These ones haven't sold out yet,
but they will.
So register early.
Everyone down under,
we know when I was in Brizzy sure.
Frizzy,
how's in Brizzy and we did a little book signing.
I did a little book signing,
and there was people from all over Australia there.
They came.
Brizzy did you netting out when you were in Brizzy that the Australians tend to
do that very thing with words.
They'll shorten them and then put an e or o at day.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
So the Aussies do that with their seat names.
They're Ozzie's boom.
Yeah.
Well,
there you go.
I kind of incorporated that one.
I've been there twice.
Right.
And Yeah,
I noticed that.
And I liked it.
The first SAS guy I worked with,
you know what his name was?
Well,
there was two.
The first one's name was Dutchie.
Dutchie was his whole name.
I produced long Dutch name.
And the other one's name was Tom and then Nikki,
right?
Sure.
Yeah.
It's 100%.
We're batting a hundred.
Yeah.
Bat a thousand.
I was doing it,
well,
I guess what would be called a mini documentary.
One of the Times I went there and um,
one of the guy's name is Jason row big.
It's a black belt under Hixon Gracie.
So it's with him and he,
you eat the way he'd explained when people are like,
Hey,
what are you guys doing?
He'd be like,
oh,
we're making a little doco
for,
you know,
for this thing or whatever.
And um,
then people understood,
oh,
they didn't exactly.
And I was like,
doc,
oh,
I like that.
It's good,
but yet,
man,
so yeah,
incorporate that into your thing.
So cool.
Yeah.
Australia,
we'll be down there.
Chicago,
Denver.
Uh,
also we have Yaffe Overwatch.
Now if you're looking to bring experienced and tested leaders into your
organization on the civilian side,
we've got military spec ops and combat aviators that are leaders that have been
trained and have been tested and they're moving into the civilian sector to come
and help your company go to f,
overwatch.com.
And if you want to keep,
you know,
sort of kicking it with us,
we're available on the Inter webs on Twitter,
on Instagram and on Facebook.
E Baja Echo
is an echo.
Charles and I am at jockowillink and thanks to all our military personnel out
there
that are out there protecting our freedom and to all the vets that have served
and have protected our great niche nation and a special thanks to how three the
sea wolves for doing what you did 24 hours a day.
Two support and save troops on the ground thanks to all of human of course to
dentist rally.
Thanks for coming on.
It's amazing to meet you and thanks for sharing your history and the history of
the sea wolves with us.
Can't say that enough.
Thank you.
Thanks to police law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
EMT,
correctional officer's border patrol,
first responders have all kinds.
Thanks for holding the line for us.
24 hours a day here at the home front
and to everyone else out there,
if you're feeling a little outgunned by the world,
think about,
think about those words,
scramble the Sea Wolves,
and then go out on the attack.
No matter the weather or the environment or the enemy fire.
You got problems going hot
and get after it.
Until next time.
This is echo and Jocko
out.